there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hello folks time for another
episode this is episode 159 admin
Canberra yeah we're finally getting
around to doing old wood kemper Big Ed
as they call him yeah the co-ed killer
yeah he's kind of a sad sack I uh
this guy you know in some ways I have
some empathy for him you know what I
mean cuz this guy was treated pretty
badly by his mom but still you know you
hear about what he did and then you're
like well [ __ ] that dude you know I mean
this yeah yeah and I don't want to get
into that a little bit more later he
killed cats man he did even killed cats
so you know no yeah I I just I don't
have any patience for that kind of stuff
but yeah those [ __ ] up that's the
thing it's like the problem about like
the whole he was abused by no I'm not
saying that he wasn't abused by his
mother me you know he probably was but
you have to understand that a lot of
stuff about his mother is coming from
his perspective and his point of view it
may not be true and I kind of feel like
you know even if it's not entirely
fabricated I feel like he's just seeing
it from his particular perspective so it
might be exaggerated or he might be you
know what I mean what does he you think
money has mild schizophrenia isn't stuff
too so yeah he might have imagined some
of this abuse in certain ways or
magnified it yeah I mean it's impossible
to tell and is a bad you know but it's
like a it's like a really weird case and
I've seen like and I was watching like a
whole bunch of different documentaries
about this and a lot of them just kind
of repeat the stuff about like you know
his mom abusing him stuff and like I
said I'm not saying that that didn't
happen I'm just saying I think we should
take it with a grain of salt because
most of that should is coming from him
and I think that he's very good at
manipulating people into feeling sorry
for him and like you know kind of
wasting his blame off on other
because he's one of those guys that's
like it was always something else but
he's also very good at and a lot of the
people that have interviewed him have
said this like even the guys that were
behind mine hunter you know the two guys
that wrote the book that that show was
based on who both interviewed him at
length you know in the early days of the
FBI's Behavioral Sciences unit they
found him very likable very self-aware
he's clearly very intelligent he has
very high IQ but I question how much of
that is sincere and how much of it
because I've watched like hours and
hours of interviews with him cuz once
you get him started talking he won't
stop talking man he just goes on and on
he loves to [ __ ] talk attention
that's what I mean so um one I don't
know how seriously you can take a lot of
the [ __ ] that he says and to I think
he's very very good at manipulating
people's emotions and making him seem
very much like a nice guy but I don't
think I don't think it's genuine I mean
I've never met him
it seems genuine if you watch because I
was even kind of falling for it I was
watching this thing going yeah he does
kind of seem like a nice guy I can see
that and I'm like he [ __ ] like Ted
Bundy it's like oh he's so he's so
handsome and so this is that I'm like he
[ __ ] people severed heads you guys so
you know what I mean these are extreme
sexual perversions and people have to
die for them yeah they're physical
gratification yeah that's pretty [ __ ]
low and I mean as normal quote-unquote
and his likable quote unquote as ed
Kemper comes across yeah I mean you
can't forget what the [ __ ] he did and
there's just like no there's just no
excuse for it you know what I mean it's
like as much as he wants to believe in
fleece Johnson booty War II gave a
[ __ ]
a choice we could do this a hard way and
he was always yes he's been released
from prison did you know that No
yeah I still haven't watched yeah he's
out he got it really started a couple
years ago now ed Kemper has not I like
I'd like to have fleece Johnson booty
warrior on the show that'd be awesome
oh are we sure that that's a good idea
they're not like stories of you know how
booty was more important to drink of
water that's what he said
yeah more important than drinking water
think of it I'm thinking about it you
should see like how long he's looked
like how long can you go without
drinking water and how long can you go
without booty wore earring booty warrior
right yeah if you guys don't know I'm
talking about just going go on YouTube
and just search for a fleece Johnson
booty warrior you will see MSNBC did a
show he's obsessed
called it like I went out there to go
make some Kukulcan right oh wow
yeah ninja stole it see isn't that weird
because you didn't know that you were
out of guava until just now like right
before we started recording this show
and all this somebody commented on the
last episode that they said said Tom
ninjas ninjas stole your guava yeah that
[ __ ] was in here he was funny was
either him or he's psychic he gotta be a
ninja there was no footprint that uses a
ninja he took your and didn't even leave
any footprints he just magic tin like
like a cheetah Kim he used some of those
like ninja disappearance technique dude
but he was behind the curtain the whole
time
yeah I'm give him give him a free shirt
all right so let's do a couple of brief
shoutouts as I have announced on the
last couple episodes faceless villain 3
is out in all the formats and it's real
in micro ebook audiobook and I'm already
sold many many copies and like I said on
our for our patrons
I actually gave them
first dibs at latex um because I have
like a certain amount of free codes
right reviews yeah it is really really
helpful what we can get up there on
Amazon okay not so much what's that ASSA
CX that one's not as important but on an
audible audible yeah on Amazon itself
though the more we can get right there
the better
yeah and I know a couple of you have
written reviews already or like UBC have
to like write it's just you know star
review that's fine too it's like
anything that you know you think it puts
puts ratings it kind of puts ratings on
it is really good because like I said
nobody wants to buy something just an
audio books alone I think you sold 12
the first day and what 18 19 of them the
second something like that yes yes and
it's also like selling some of the some
of the first two bonds yeah oh yeah okay
now if all you wanted to and then some
of the other stuff like mammoth
mountains even yeah that would happen
because goes into the new section well
because the thing is it's like when part
three came out I was hoping every we go
oh she did write one and two and she did
right through so I'm just lying and like
I never got around to but I really like
she is a reliable producer she's gonna
do it most of the time yeah I'm gonna
make sure that [ __ ] out you're gonna
make sure make sure yeah we stand there
like a supervisor yeah so like I said if
you're into true crime yeah yeah pick it
up
in whatever format yeah and then that
collection of fictions gonna be out
there in a couple months - yeah I'm
working on doing I've done the the print
version and the eBook version I haven't
uploaded the mint but I've redone and
repackaged and stuff and then I've been
recording the audiobook version and it's
about halfway done maybe a little bit
more than halfway okay but um the first
see the first edition of Associated
Melanie's had 26 stories I actually
added four stories I think and like
expanded a little bit of like the story
notes and things like that so it's gonna
be yeah and it's gonna have an audio
version I know everybody wants audiobook
audio book sells like crazy they do seem
to sell
well like I said UT yeah they're good
for people it's like you know it's like
white people listen to podcast stuff
like that because you can you know when
you're out running room commuting or big
enough so we got it up there to wear
decent sized audio book now yeah I'm
like I said with all my fiction that I'm
repackaging I want every one to be 400
pages at least so that makes it
everything decent-sized yes so people
feel like it's so people feel like it's
like worth the money where's mine right
but yeah so there's that and also I'd
like to say hello to our newest patron
who is named talena ort Elena I'm not
sure which way you pronounce it but
thank you and also I'd like to give a
shout-out to our longtime patron weapons
and stuff 73 who recently increased his
support by a very large margin yeah
thanks thank you very much we were just
talking the other day he was sitting
there bastion on the old US Army
gas-mask
the older generation that we used I said
straight on that that was a decent gas
mask but for what we were using it for
best thing about it is that it was
ambidextrous you could shoot either
right or left-handed for but then he
were late we replaced it with a better
what so I kind of set him straight on
he's gonna come up with a new review on
that man that that mask I forgot what
the name of that mask was I think was
called the m17 I think a little too hard
based upon a clone a Czechoslovakian
clone of the mask because that's not the
way that mask actually was when they
issued it to us we liked it well there
yeah and it was mostly just against CS
and smoke anyway nerve agent would just
kill you we tried to protect ourselves
from with all those [ __ ] equipment
but all of us knew that you'd die anyway
they were just trying to mitigate it
mostly for morale yeah just make you
feel maybe feel a little bit better
maybe cooking a mission but if you got a
nerve agent if you got hit a nerve agent
even if you already had that suit on
it's only a matter of time for it got in
there yeah this bug spray for humans man
and that ship is [ __ ] highly
concentrated you could contaminate
yourself taking the suit off during the
deacon
nomination process kill does that [ __ ]
would get every just everywhere and then
you're in a crowd of guys that are all
contaminated and they're trying to hose
you all down at once you know the inside
of a big tent filled with [ __ ] Clorox
and bubble soap and [ __ ] and it's going
everywhere they don't they don't really
expect you to live that long even to get
to the decon you know yeah
decontamination phase man you you're
gonna be doping yourself up with
atropine and those atropine kits that
kill you they were [ __ ] overdoses too
if you got hit a nerve agent you were
dead you know yeah yeah all right so are
we ready to talk about are we weddy I'm
sorry I had a bit of an Elmer Fudd
moment there um are we ready to talk
about ready ready to talk about yeah
Edmund Kemper yes good get involved in
this oh all right so this guy like I
said otherwise known as the co-ed killer
the co-ed butcher can we talk about how
weird the phrase co-ed is especially
like yeah I could see how they used it
like back in the old days like when when
the norm was you know single sex
education which was the norm like when
like the 19th century or something like
that but what's the 70s rolled around
why are they still called like female
students stories they're just students
all right that's dumb I don't know I
mean my grandmother was mystified when I
said told her one time this is back in
the 80s you know things in the 80s a
lady doesn't say my my buddies went to
the University of Michigan and that
girls living next door to them in the
dorms and she was flabbergasted she was
like women women are living in the same
dorms as the men as of yet it doesn't
the same apartment says meant why can't
they live in the same dorm they're not
gonna say I don't know that yeah see
it's like I never even well that can't
be nobody would let their kids do that
and I just yeah but they're not kids
though late 70s I think that's if she
was nice she was in her late 70s then
she just couldn't she just couldn't just
didn't go so well the thing is it's like
dorms it's like I was just thought about
like an apartment that's all I was like
an apartment right and it's like you
know men and women live in the same
apartment building yeah so she still
thought it was 1860
but yeah now something that a lot of
people remark was probably one of the
first things that people remark upon
when they talk about Edie Kemper is his
size
he was a gigantic gigantic person he was
almost 7 feet tall 6 foot 9 yeah
actually yeah it's because his mom was 6
feet tall and his dad was 6 foot 8 so he
was he's this big giant and he was
almost like 300 pounds I mean even was a
teenager he was already 6 foot 4
so if you see photographs and I found
some online you know after he got
arrested and stuff and you're watching
like the cops like taking him into
custody and stuff and he's just look
he's like twice their size
he looks like a [ __ ] sasquatch yeah
said his hands were the size of a
catcher's mitt yeah he was just like
this massive massive person which like
you know kind of makes him scarier but
you know and so whatever well we'll get
into that so he was born in California
now he actually he had two siblings like
he had a sister that was older I think
she was 6 years older and then he had
another sister that was two and a half
years younger now his mom's name was
Claire Nell and his dad's name was also
Edmund Kemper he was like Edmund Kemper
junior or something like that now even
from a young age and like I said this ED
Kemper comes up a lot when you're
talking about the nature-nurture debate
like you know in serial killing because
I've seen some people think that you
know maybe if he hadn't had to live with
his mother he would have turned out all
right some other people saying no he was
just already [ __ ] up from the
beginning and it wouldn't have mattered
what his upbringing was I'm not really
sure where I stand on that and there's
obviously no way of knowing because it's
too late now but you know as I said this
is always kind of like a really
complicated sort of issue uh you know
with some of these studies that have
been doing recently I've been you know
listen to these [ __ ] doctors and PhDs
and stuff and you know and of course you
know told you Steve and you that excited
this he's my best buddy I'd ask him
about stuff like that's it he he says
that genes define everything said that
you know that's probably in his
you know and it's interactive with the
environment yeah so you put that guy in
a certain environment and that stuff
activates
I don't lean toward that as well so it's
still there though oh yeah yeah and I
don't think it goes away no and I think
first of all you have to be a psychopath
and psychopathy is something genetic
yeah you inherit it yeah so even if it's
even if the serial killer mode is not
activated that sucker it's sitting up in
a psychopath and you know I had
high-functioning psychopaths in my
family I know what they're like they
follow rules and they use those rules to
[ __ ] you over
yeah and they and they they kind of lord
over you you know who I'm talking about
yeah and you know and they never broke a
law but you know you know one when you
see one
yeah you know what it is a very
particular type of an obviously brand
[ __ ] yeah Brendan obviously not all
of them are serial killers cuz armed
killers are thankfully rare bond can be
judges calm yeah later no a big business
owner but it's the same it's as
Cincinnati's a certain type of [ __ ]
they're very shallow and they think a
lot of themselves okay Jeffrey Epstein
everything that every the way that do is
described by all those people who knew
him that that's it right there a
high-functioning psychopath because he
had people in the scientific community
that that would would hang out with him
on his little island and they talk about
things that they were going to invest in
and some of them have said what you know
told stories about him you know that
they weren't no allegations you know
what I mean about the with the young
girls but you know guys and some of them
do have allegations but the ones that
we're talking didn't and they said the
same thing you know as same kana [ __ ]
mentality Lord and over you pretend that
they know more than you when clearly
they don't rules are for other people
not for them the rules on you yeah yeah
yeah and like I said that that is
actually a very very common personality
type and obviously all of those people
don't become serial killers but that
type of person if
it's gonna be a serial killer a lot of
them are if that Alexa Khalid a safe but
with low / low charisma a lot of times
kind of a maybe average or a lot of them
I think a lot of Psychopaths I think are
below average intelligence but they get
caught yes ed Kemper was a was an
exception because he had an almost yeah
yeah like an almost genius level I do
and he's also and please someone correct
me if I'm wrong he might be the only
serial killer that turned himself in
yeah I guess he had had enough well once
once he once he did his mom and he
didn't figure you know he had much of a
future yeah so I don't know if he would
have been caught or not because no one
suspected him you know up until that
point and he was he was friends with
cops and [ __ ] I'm pretty sure he
believed that his mom's what the set was
the center of his problems anyway and
she might oh he definitely did yeah so
he's talked [ __ ] about her all the time
yeah there may been some to it yeah I'm
sure there might have been I don't think
that came out of nowhere no but I do
think that you have to you have to
consider the source well once you're
once you're a psychic a high-functioning
psychopath the smallest slight it is
even worse so you know maybe they're
more sensitive to that [ __ ] well because
they think everything has he directed at
that right and that they're too good to
have anything bad happen to them so of
course she's sitting there busting his
balls all the time then he thing they
take serious offense yeah and another
thing that complicates this issue which
is something that I've like been
thinking about is that his mom by all
accounts was she didn't really know how
to deal with him she was afraid of him
like you know the story goes that she
made him sleep in the basement because
she was afraid that he would molest his
sisters but in a way she was right you
know what I mean she knew he was a
weirdo she used it was stuff that's what
I mean she knew something was the matter
with him
and I don't think she knew how to deal
with it yeah he may have been doing some
yeah so you can't really like blame her
entirely because she [ __ ] called it
yeah actually and like a lot of his
family members thought he was weird he
just got shunted from you know family
member and a family member because
nobody would really want to do with
I was such a weirdo you know what I mean
so yeah that was that whole thing so
alright so now apparently when Edie
Kemper was 9 years old his parents
separated and then four years later they
divorced now at this point
Edie goes and moves with his mother and
his two sisters to Helena Montana and he
really did not like it there he has
numerous times has said that his mother
was quote/unquote a man hater that that
he reminded her of her husband who she
couldn't stand and so she was constantly
berating him he was never good enough
you know she just thought he was [ __ ]
and he would never amount to anything
and again like I said he claims that
he's like he had a bedroom upstairs but
then when he started to get a little bit
older she made him sleep down in the
basement in this windowless room in the
basement because she was afraid that he
would like do something to his sisters
he probably was doing something to him
that's what I mean it's like I try I
hesitate to [ __ ] on his mom too much
because like I said she [ __ ] called
it she knew that there was something the
matter with them might have been some
kind of synergy where he was giving off
his fucked-up energy and they didn't
trust him so they kind of segregated him
from other people in the family which
made it worse and then it kind of like
that's exactly what it was it was like a
feedback we got he got worse and worse
so they came and then they kept pushing
him away you know what I mean and like I
said I'm not sure if there's anything
that could have been done to prevent it
but in a way I can kind of understand
where his mom is coming from it's like
he was a huge huge dude even when he was
a teenager he was already six foot four
like I said and very heavy with very big
hands and he was just like this weird
like kind of socially who's very
socially awkward and you know he was
violent towards animals and things so
like I said I don't think she knew what
to do about him yeah so she was just
kind of like she didn't trust him and
all this [ __ ] was going and then it just
kept
you know so they just were at
loggerheads like all the time because
sounds like because he wanted affection
from her I guess and he did say and
later on interviews that he did think
that his mother loved him in her way and
that he loved her too but they just
couldn't be in the same place they were
just always at each other's throats and
you know I think like I said she might
have been a really horrible person to I
don't know I never met her
interestingly like a lot of her friends
and co-workers thought she was a lovely
person that she was very charming and
stuff but you know that's that's not
always the case like the way you act
with your kids or your spouse or
something like that isn't necessarily
what you showed your friends or
coworkers and stuff so there could have
been some other [ __ ] going on there but
like I said it's a really complicated
situation and they apparently had a very
complicated relationship
so when Ed was in school he did pretty
good like I said you know they they knew
he was quite intelligent even though he
was much bigger than the other kids he
seemed to be like afraid that they were
gonna kick his ass I'm not really sure
why um he seemed to like brood over his
parents divorce he wanted to go live
with his dad but you know later on he
did and his dad and really want to be to
be there around this time he started
torturing animals particularly cats they
had a pet cat now I don't know which
which one because he did it to two of
them as far as I know one of them he
killed with a machete and cut it up and
kept it in his closet and his mom found
it later on and then another one he
buried the cat alive and then after it
was dead he dug it up and cut off his
head and put it on a stick yeah so sorry
you deserved to die just for that I mean
that is [ __ ] up that's what I mean so
and he would do other weird things too
like his sister said oh he used to like
cut the heads off their dolls you know
cut up cut their limbs off and things
one of his favorite games to play with
his sisters was like gas chamber play
like he would get in a chair and like he
would have his sister
like time to the chair and then they
would pretend the room was filling with
poison gas and he would like try to get
out or he would pretend to get
electrocuted like [ __ ] like that so like
I said yeah although he's still alive he
hasn't because he got he actually got
convicted when they had a brief
moratorium on death but he wanted the
death penalty but in a video but yes so
so like I said he was that there's
something the matter with him like from
a pretty young age now he um
his mom just like couldn't deal with
this ass anymore so he gets sent to LA
to live with his dad and his stepmother
now the stepmother couldn't stand his
ass either and was afraid of him
justifiably so I mean even at this point
before he'd even killed anybody and he
did that at a pretty young age so but
he's already doing this [ __ ] with
animals he was just had this weird
[ __ ] [ __ ] about him and he was
enormous
so the stepmother didn't like him the
Father wasn't super jazzed about having
the kid that he let him stay there for a
while like a few months and stuff but
then he's just like no man you can't
stay here so he ended up going to stay
with his paternal grandparents who had
like a 17 acre ranch in North Fork North
Fork California their names were Maude
and Edmund Kemper senior so he was sent
there in 1963 when he was about 14 15
years old now here's where his Lowell
murderous career began because so he
starts going to school he didn't really
like it there at the farm because he
said that his grandmother and like I
said this is another thing that kind of
makes me feel like maybe he's
exaggerating some [ __ ] maybe not I don't
know but he claims that his grandmother
was just like his mom even though they
weren't related this was his paternal
this wasn't his mom's mom this was his
dad's mom so he said the grandmother was
just like she thought she was you know
had more balls than any man and she was
gonna like you know emasculate me
escalated her husband all the time like
I'm such a badass and you can't [ __ ]
do it and that she was always belittling
him and stuff like that so I said it's
very interesting how every like female
authority figure in his life his mother
and his grandmother he perceives her
that way were they really that way it's
possible sure maybe they were both like
that maybe they were both ballbusting
you know harm horrible women that was
just like hated men and just like you
know it's possible I just think it's
strange that wherever he goes that
wherever he goes every woman that like
has to tell him what to do because he's
a kid somehow she's suddenly a
ballbusting [ __ ] I just think that's
very strange
maybe he maybe he carried himself in a
way that brought that out a woman maybe
he did certain things and they were
talented that's what I think there was
some of them might have been some of
that going on like I said I don't like
to victim blame and stuff like that but
considering what he did later on I'd
really hesitate to call him a victim of
anything could be making it up yeah and
that's what I'm saying it's like all of
this stuff kind of comes from his his
say-so
um you know his grandmother and his
mother are dead and they can't defend
themselves so I'm just saying sure just
take things with a grain of salt yeah
now so as we moved in with his
grandparents at this ranch he started
going to school there and he did like
pretty good he had like average grades
um you know his teachers thought he was
alright he's you know smart but he was
kind of quiet kind of kept to himself
and all this other kind of [ __ ]
now his [ __ ] I believe it was his father
his grandfather had bought him a 22 and
he would go out hunting with it around
the ranch and stuff and they said that
he could you know he hunted rabbits and
squirrels and stuff just normal [ __ ]
like you would do on a ranch for some
reason his grandparents didn't want him
to shoot the birds they're like you can
shoot rabbits or squirrels whatever you
want just leave the birds alone for
whatever reason can't eat him I guess
that's why it's just seems pointless so
one day when he's out you know he's he's
gonna leave and he's gonna go out
hunting because him and his grandmother
had gotten
to an argument its grandma there was a
writer she wrote children's books I
believe so they get into like an
argument about a stupid thing and as
what he would usually do when he got mad
he would go out hunting and as he was
excreme' sitting at the table like in
the dining room or whatever working on a
book and he said it's okay well I'm
gonna go out hunting or whatever she's
like don't you shoot those birds or
something of that nature and apparently
he got super super pissed off and just
shot her in the head
damn so there you go now accounts differ
about how many either shot her in the
head once and twice in the back or in
the back of the head and twice in the
back some accounts say he also stabbed
her afterward but anyway he killed her I
don't believe it I don't think that's
why he did that probably not a soul
thing I don't shoot the birds I'll [ __ ]
you there's more to the story I think
well I think he kind of framed it as you
know he had been all of this [ __ ] like
in rage against her had been building up
for all of this time and I guess they
just had this like stupid argument again
like about something that they had
argued about short birds and he's just
like that was just like the final straw
that's how I took it
anyway because it does seem like and he
like I said he had such a similar
relationship with his grandmother as he
did with his mother it seemed like he
didn't want women telling him what to do
I guess big it's like you know if if his
mom told him to do some even was like a
reasonable thing evidently like he would
get like really butthurt about it and he
would like just have this rage it just
really seemed like he had this hatred he
was also terrified of women and he
admitted that himself later on
particularly women his own age and I
think that's why he ended up killing so
many of them because he was afraid of
being inadequate not knowing what to do
around them and it's like he talks about
them like they're an alien species which
a lot of these types of guys do like
they don't know how to talk to women
like like we're not human beings or
something it's like it's very very
strange I was a little bit autistic he
might have had something like that yeah
you know
I mean it's like not to [ __ ] on like
autistic people because you know they
don't usually end up killing people so
yeah it's a spectrum and there's a lot
of different forms and there's a lot of
different variations of it he definitely
does he was very very socially awkward
yeah
but interestingly later on it's almost
kind of like he learned not to be like
like how to fake it like how to be a
fake normal person which is how he ended
up like luring people into his car and
stuff like that because you couldn't do
that if he just acted like a freakazoid
you know what I mean right
but yeah so he kills his grandmother
dead wraps her head in a towel and drags
her body upstairs and like sticks it in
a closet or some [ __ ] like that
now his grandfather comes home I believe
he'd been at the grocery store as
grandfather time is about 72 years old
and because okay now Eid later said it
was either because he didn't want to get
in trouble for killing his grandma or
because he didn't want his grandfather
to be upset that his wife was dead so he
walks out to his grandfather who's
getting the groceries out of the car and
just shoots him dead - yeah so he killed
his grandparents when he was 15 years
old dan then after he did that he called
his mom in Montana and said I killed my
grandparents what should I do
and she said called the police yeah and
she probably added you [ __ ] yeah
maybe I'm just done but you speculate
can you imagine
well I kind of feel like her I feel like
his mom probably wasn't all that
surprised right you know what I mean
it's like his everything she thought
about it turned out to be true she's
probably like oh well I was expecting
this phone call call the cops dumbass so
he called the cops and he waited there
on the porch of the grandparents house
until the cops got there now
like I said he was only 15 years old at
the time he was a minor so he ended up
going to Atascadero State Hospital for
criminally insane juveniles or whatever
now this is where they determined
that Edie Kemper had in had an IQ I've
seen 136 and 145 but either way that's a
very very very high IQ hot top 1/2
percentile now another thing that he was
able to do was that he was so personable
and so intelligent and seemed to have a
lot of self awareness about himself and
his behavior that he got really
interested in the psychologists and he
would shadow them and he learned a lot
of their stuff now
he ended up memorizing the answers to
like 28 different psychological tests
that they would give at the hospital
like two different offenders and whatnot
so I feel like his time there I mean he
was young he was there from like 15 when
he was 15 20 was 21 I believe he was let
out um
but his time there I think was very it's
his [ __ ] up thing to say but it was
very valuable to him later on in his
serial killing career because he learned
all the lingo he learned how to appear
normal because he had memorized this
whole battery of tests he knew what to
say to the psychiatrist's to get them to
think that he was getting better so I
feel like as I said even though when you
watch interviews with him and like I
said I kind of almost fell for it too
when you watch interviews but he does
come across as very personable very nice
he almost comes across as remorseful
that he's like sorry for what he did he
comes across as he really like seems to
understand what was going on in his head
why I did this you know maybe it was
because of this maybe was quit and it
sounds like very insightful but I also
feel like he is extremely extremely
manipulative
yes it's grandstanding and being in this
exactly I think that's what it is he's
very good at it
he's very good at it because he's very
good at making himself and like I said
everybody I know of that's interviewed
him said I liked him he seemed like a
nice guy but he know
what you want to see exactly exactly and
I think that people forget that and it's
easy to because he comes across as just
like a nice normal dude
even when and then like it's almost
shock shocking like when he's just
talking in this normal voice and he's
like yeah and then I cut off her head
and I was like [ __ ] the head show you
know what I mean it's like it's this
[ __ ] incongruous crazy [ __ ] and he
hung out with cops all the time and they
didn't suspect it that if you gave him a
woman and turned you back on and even
killed that woman so it's like he's not
a nice guy or anything he's just very
very good at manipulating people and
getting them to see what he wants he's
like he lives to kill women
yeah he's one of those yeah yeah it
really does seem like it's a habit he
can break yeah like I said at least the
[ __ ] turned himself in I mean I
wish more serial killers would do that
actually I wish they wouldn't even
become serial killers in the first place
but if you're gonna do that at least
[ __ ] turn yourself in and save
everybody a lot of [ __ ] grief but um
yeah so they asked him like why he had
killed his grandmother he didn't really
have a reason for that he just said I
wanted to see what it would be like to
kill the grandma that's basically what
he and he just said he killed his
grandfather because he felt bad he
didn't want her fine he didn't want him
finding the dead body of his wife or I I
suspect that he was more afraid that
although he I guess he wasn't afraid to
get caught cuz he called the cops and
turn himself in for that do you want to
face his grand dad after that that's
probably what it was because I feel like
if Edie Kemper feels any emotions it's
only for his own ass he doesn't feel
emotion or care about anyone else
he cares about himself he can like make
himself cry and all this other kind of
crap but I I think he only cares about
his own self usually when they're like
this it's all about them anyway yeah
that's exactly do anybody else that's
exactly what I think is his issue so
yeah so um so he spends a lot of time in
this in Atascadero State Hospital now he
apparently really liked it there he
thrived there he also like I said not
only got really good at passing those
psychological tests and like learning
what other people expected of him and
what it took to seem like a normal
person he also sadly enough got a lot of
tips from some of the other [ __ ]
criminals that were in there
particularly from rapists and he really
really liked hanging out with the serial
rapist who told him things like well you
have to kill him like to eliminate the
witness if you were going to go ahead
and do that you know what I mean so you
know protip I guess so he's like right
he's like [ __ ] taking oh yeah good
point is that [ __ ] up that's [ __ ] up
man it's like goddammit
so now at this stage I don't I don't
know if he was like a virgin or not like
through his whole life because he did
kind of hint around it sounds like he is
virgin though that yeah well at least
with living women well yeah I think
we're dead women I don't think that he
didn't want that woman to be there
yeah by some accounts like he did he did
rape one girl but she was unconscious
and then he killed her that's not the
same that's what I mean so it's not
watching he couldn't deal with he
couldn't deal with wins judgment yeah he
had performance anxiety
yeah a big time so yeah there was so
though there was that whole thing now so
while he's in the hospital you know he's
working very hard he's learning all this
stuff and he said he'd had like a
religious awakening or whatever and like
studied the Bible and [ __ ] you know just
like they always [ __ ] do and um now
they decided that in 1969 when they gave
him all the tests and like I said he had
memorized all the [ __ ] answers they
decided that he was quote-unquote normal
and safe and they would let him back out
into the world now when he was let out
in 1969 you have to think he's been
institutionalized for you know six years
at this point I believe it was six years
so he missed that whole summer of love
hippie [ __ ] and everything he missed all
that so he's coming out of the mental
hospital at twenty-one years old and all
the other kids his age you know there's
all he's in California there's like all
this hippie stuff going on and he just
looks like this dorky like short hair
kind of conservative dude even the 15
yeah and he doesn't really know and he's
been like hanging out with old people
his whole life cuz he's been likely you
know living with his grandparents and
[ __ ] like that so he has no idea I mean
when he came out and likes one of the
interviews that I saw he said the kids
when I came out were just like speaking
a different language I didn't know
anything about that like he just missed
that whole you know you know that whole
like societal whatever so he had missed
that now his big thing after he got out
was that he wanted to be a cop he was
another cop groupie a lot of Lamar um I
don't know entirely well I guess I'm
entirely sure why that might be they
always seem like there's a like
authoritarian yes yes that's very
interesting yeah it's funny cuz it's
it's not military it's always police
that way mostly yeah you can tell people
that you know what to do yeah yeah yeah
I think they get off on yeah yeah the
low-power trap giving people tickets and
[ __ ] yeah yeah sending people to jail so
if he wanted to get a law enforcement he
wanted to get a you know police academy
now I wouldn't like to be arrested by
that dude but yeah but um so turns out
though cuz you know how it's see I
didn't even know this until I started
reading about this case but you know how
like cops they have like a minimum
height requirement they also have a
maximum height requirement and he was
too tall to be a cop so you'd be a hell
of a [ __ ] wrestler though that's what
he should've yeah yeah good wrestling or
basketball or something like that where
his height would have been yeah you know
you need to like play to your strengths
ma'am you're that [ __ ] giant yeah
Andre the Giant there early version
Andre the Giant yeah and he could have
got like all his aggression out that way
then we wouldn't even tell him this
story on the story then he could get he
would just be a normal guy and he'd
still be a normal old guy now like
long story and making them skeletons in
his closet dance call himself the
Decapitator mexico's luchador masks on
because he was in california somebody's
gonna photoshop that out yeah ed keppra
with a lid or a mask on yeah so yeah so
he wanted to go so we want to go to
police academy but they wouldn't let him
because he was too tall um so all this
time he was kind of still on parole like
you know cuz they had let him out of the
mental hospital so he was still going
back for you know analyses by the
psychiatrists now the psychiatrists at
the hospital strongly suggested they
said we're gonna let him out we think
he's you know rehabilitating stuff but
do not send him back to live with his
mother because it is a trigger for him
and we don't think it's gonna work out
very well several psychiatrists at the
hospital made that determination they
said please do not send him to live with
his mother
but of course do the Youth Authority
were just like they were overworked they
had all this other [ __ ] no one was
really watching him he didn't have a job
he didn't have any money so he ended up
back with his mother in Santa Cruz
California now let's talk about Santa
Cruz for a second because during this
period in the 1970s it was known as the
murder capital of the world because you
only have at kemper yeah so two other
[ __ ] serial killers run around when
it was a serial killer was a spree
killer now if you guys have seen the
classic 1987 movie The Lost Boys where
they talk where the fictional town of
Santa Clara Santa Carla rather you know
with the vampires everything where
they're talking about the murder capital
of the world this is what they're
talking about they're talking about
Santa Cruz you know I mean and they
actually shot the movie in Santa Cruz as
well so this is what they were referring
to now the thing about Santa Cruz what
ended up happening at around this time
late 60s early 70s was it you know it
was kind of a higher-end like kind of a
beach community like so you know people
have beach houses there and [ __ ] like
that a lot of tourists upscale houses
things of that nature now people start
to notice like I said the hippy movement
and all the hippies kind of coming in
now when you get a bunch of hippies
coming in distant it's not necessarily
the hippies doing the killin I mean
other than like Charles Manson's weirdos
and [ __ ] like that but some serial
killers will come there just because
there's a transient victim pool you know
I mean because a lot of these [ __ ]
hippies were just going there and like
hanging out and living in the street or
you know living like squat in various
places
I like the World's Fair what's his name
HH Holmes exactly they just go after a
particulars that go you know it's like
oh it's like the watering hole like that
the [ __ ] it go where lion goes like to
get the wildebeest they're gonna go
where the women are really and where
they're not gonna look out a place when
they go there cuz everybody's there yeah
and particularly in the 60s and 70s when
there were so many young women in one
place a lot of them were in the hippie
movement there were a lot of colleges
there so there was a lot of like young
attractive women and hitchhiking was a
big thing you know the the whole US
highway system was kind of still a new
concept and people you know still have
that trusting thing where they're just
like getting strangers cars I said well
that's just in thing it needs something
although that trust in thing although I
guess people do it now with rockin Ober
then lift and stuff you still get into a
stranger's car it still isn't the same
though that's true criminals were more
bold then yeah the forensics and they
didn't live in a date information basis
yeah you could get away with all because
like you know what I mean I wanted to
get away with [ __ ] now it really is and
it really does seem like this era is
gone obvious because there's so much so
much of this this year so many serial
killers that came about in the 70s and
why there were so many of that
particular type was I think because of
the societal upheaval and all these new
things the societal tensions are no
longer there yeah so it's not the same
than proliferation of porn I think has
bled off a lot of that energy he asked
me I probably has to be honest with you
in you know like I said I'm not anti
religion but I think the decline of
religion kinda has
kind of made the numbers these guys fall
because it always tends to be some kind
of a moral conflict in these guys
its genetic though - yeah but like I
said it's always like a perfect storm of
this you think this is a bunch of stuff
because this serial killers also have
this you know punish these [ __ ]
attitude yes partly that's your mission
style killers right and there's always
kind of like sin involved in that these
women are sinful I got take about yeah
yeah I mean you know I mean they're just
having too much sex and I got raping
they kill them yeah I'm a punishment for
being [ __ ] yeah and that's almost kind
of like a some kind of bitter twisted
religious it is viewpoint of it and I
feel like if you don't wrote and I think
I'm probably mentioned this before but I
always feel like you know maybe if
Jeffrey Dahmer had grown up in in a time
and place and with parents that were not
so dead sent dead set against
homosexuality then he might have turned
out okay maybe not tell Wacha the
attitude of bitter third world in sales
remember that and also they got him in
the first world remember that oh pretty
boy that decided he was gonna kill those
people because women didn't like him
which one there's been obviously he's
making all videos every arrived
everything more than what he thinks he's
[ __ ] fashion model yeah yeah yeah it's
Ellie Rogers probably the most basic
it's like one of those kind of like one
of those that always it always kills me
it kills me the entitlement yeah they
actually think and the scary thing about
Elliott is we just don't love me we
should take a [ __ ] show on that
douche I have a lot of stuff yeah yeah
but um you know what I mean but the
thing that kills me about that guy and
those types of people the entitlement to
me is just it's breathtaking because
they see women going about their normal
I'm just doing normal [ __ ] they don't
know he exists and yet somehow it is a
slight against him all these [ __ ] are
doing this stuff like like they need his
permission
even though they don't know who he is
right that that's just so [ __ ] weird
to me I don't understand that mindset at
all like I don't understand people who
think that just people do and [ __ ] that
don't even know you exist
so you think that the people are doing
[ __ ] at you yeah it's so narcissistic
dudes that do not understand the dynamic
of women the dynamic of of the
relationship between men men and women I
talk big [ __ ] on this show before
people calling me Chad Chad of chance
look I got pictures of proof I could
back [ __ ] up yeah the reason why the
jeans jeans are a factor health is a
factor but really I think I [ __ ] happen
because I didn't really care yeah I
didn't care that much I was just being
myself having fun you know in drama and
hanging out with guys you know I mean
and I guess the energy attracted women
yeah that just starts in high school
yeah yeah for men it always starts at
high school that energy somehow could
kind of women are attracted to that it's
because you're not you know key you're
not desperate you're not just putting
out looking because I think that's one
of the most that's one of the biggest
turn offs
I had to anybody yeah I had other
interests yeah I was hanging out with
guys who had other interests yeah and we
were doing we were succeeding at what we
were doing
yeah and we were and that of course it's
like success breeds success yeah that's
what's happening and like I said it's
always kind of like it's confidence it's
kind of feeling like and people who are
confident yeah don't like desperately
yeah pursue like people vent to that
don't art that aren't interested yeah we
never really had that yeah and I think
that's kind of a big part of it and
that's and that's kind of what I think
and like I said I I think there's like a
misconception that oh you know women
only like [ __ ] or something like
that it's not that it's just they like
dudes that are confident not [ __ ]
not cocky not and then what is not
arrogant just
what happened ended up having me and all
my friends is that these guys that are
like you start to gravitate so then the
next thing you know you're in a group of
guys that are all along that same
profile yeah and then you know what I
mean you're learning from each other
yeah and then there's all the women that
are kind of like the female equivalent
of you in that same yeah as all those
girls were winners - yeah and I don't
say winners in the way they're like you
know the Jodie and Buffy you know
theythey were goth girls and punk
rockers and [ __ ] and they all turned out
great
yeah yeah I know where they are I know
where they are
yeah still still talking about Facebook
you know we're where the main players
were they all turned everybody was
confident for some reason these guys
miss out on this and they stay down
different directions like a perverted
version and it's self-fulfilling yeah so
which is bad because once you get on
that road it's not hard to get off it's
hard to get over does it dominate your
destiny isn't that what [ __ ] Yoda said
yeah once you get started on because it
seems like once you have that mindset
like I said that Elliot Rodger had it's
like look at all these [ __ ] going
around with their boyfriends and none of
them will have sex with me even though
they didn't even know he existed he was
just they were just going about their
normal life they even know who the [ __ ]
he was he'd never even bothered to
introduce himself to them or try to go
out on dates or anything he just thought
that women should just fall into his
[ __ ] lap apparently I guess that's
what he thought but and once you start
going along the path I was on bad [ __ ]
would happen and you didn't take it
personally because II didn't identify
with it that was just accident right
yeah you go by accident banika I am
really with me I just [ __ ] up yeah but
if you go down the other way like la
major went right you know or like
[ __ ] Edie Kemper went right then it's
going to feed into it itself because it
works it works yeah if you have that
mindset that women are denying me
something that I deserve they should be
coming at me they should be doing this
right then everything they do is bad is
bad and it reflects on you and it makes
you matter and matter that's why it's so
dangerous and I think it's really kind
of I mean particularly now a days when
you get like a smash
and stuff it's really important to like
identify this type of personality and
like kind of try and steer them in
another direction because it's really
hard to get off imagining that what
they're doing is everything is very
introspective they're only looking in it
themselves or they're going inward yeah
me and my buddies were never like that
we were always like going outward yeah I
really didn't want we weren't really
introspective that much yeah because we
were too busy yeah you know I mean we
were interacting with the environment
too much yeah we didn't sit around
worried about what our feelings about it
were yeah and what that person how that
person looked at me you know it's not
really I mean it was a low priority I
mean some introspection is good
everybody needs that
I'm not saying but too much
introspection can be bad because you
will like anxiety yourself yes you will
overthink better to go with the flow if
you ask me it is I've had more success
I'm trying to remain aloof from myself
just get into the things that you like
and just try to make things and build
things and and like you said don't don't
[ __ ] turn in and just like over
overanalyze things yeah like you said
don't take the [ __ ] other people do you
can't take it personally because a lot
of it's not about you right it's about
them you know what I mean so I don't
think that Edie Kemper Rogers ever what
happens it's unusual
yeah means it's not you right exactly
yes so I was talking a little bit about
Santa Cruz because I was saying that for
a time it was considered the murder
capital of the world just because Kemper
and there were two other guys now at the
time you know in the early 1970s when
all these hippies were coming to Santa
Cruz it was all the hitchhiking is all
the you know female students and stuff
now at this point and if you've watched
mine hunter you know I'm not gonna spoil
anything for sure but I just finished
watching the second season that's such a
good show and the first one is kind of
focused a lot on Edie Kemper he's sort
of mentioned in the second one too but
the second one's mostly about the
Atlanta child murders so as you know as
most people know if they've seen that
show or read the books that you know
that it was based on the concept of
serial killer didn't really come about
until the early 70s and a lot of it was
from inner
Edmund Kemper and other killers like him
I remember the time they really didn't
have it nailed out really to the
eighties they didn't really because they
were still interviewing all this food
they were trying to figure out because
at the time like in the early 70s I saw
this one estimate that about 95% of
murders in the United States at the time
were situational there were domestic
disputes or you know two guys in a fight
or something like that
so the serial killer thing even though
there have been serial killers since the
beginning of recorded history as you'll
know if you've read any of my books cuz
you know that goes back a long way but
we didn't really have the language to
talk about it you didn't really have an
understanding of it about the you know
about the pathology so it was kind of
like a new thing even though it has sort
of been around before that so in the
early 1970s in Santa Cruz
there were several killers running
around and actually some of Kemper's
murders got pinned on this other guy not
like officially but they were trying to
pin him on this other guy just so they
could close the case because this other
guy was caught before Kemper was before
Kemper turned himself in so there was
one guy named John Lindley Frazer and
about the end of 1970 he actually
murdered five people it was a whole
family and the dad was a doctor and he
also killed the doctor's secretary um he
was a weird now he actually was kind of
a hippie he was like a weird like
schizophrenic super environmentalist
like he thought that that humans were
messing up the natural environment and
somehow killing a family of people was
gonna solve the problem so I don't know
he was loose in the car he was lip read
I guess by five people so when I don't
know he would seem like kind of like a
Charles Manson type yeah um but yeah he
did like the whole the same thing as
Manson he was it was like a home
invasion type of thing and he was on
like a lot of drugs and [ __ ] like that
now there were also another series of
murders in late 1972 and early
1973 and this is a so it was over like a
four month period and these were this
was interesting because it was like a
spree kill I guess her serial killer but
there was no torture no mutilation no
victim profile he just kind of killed
people at random this guy was named
Herbert Mullin
and when they caught him he was 25 years
old he had killed four campers at a
campsite he killed a priest he killed a
guy who was just doing some gardening he
just walked by and shot him killed a
young girl and he killed a mom and her
two kids now apparently this is what I
was watching murder with friends earlier
and they were talking about at Kemper
it's a really good podcast they also do
a YouTube show but they sent it this guy
killed people to prevent earthquakes I
guess is what he thought he had some
like [ __ ] weird I don't have to do
way of looking at it if I kill this
[ __ ] earthquake will not happen
well there's no way they shake see see
it didn't happen yeah that's textbook
like man yeah see the thing is he was in
kind of the same situation as Kemper
because he had actually been
institutionalized for a time and was
considered dangerous but later on was
let out as an outpatient now he was on
anti static psychotic medication but he
decided of his own volition that he was
going to stop taking it and obviously he
needed that [ __ ] because as soon as he
stopped taking it
he went around shooting random people so
you know yeah he said he heard voices
and all that other kind of stuff yeah he
thought California was gonna have a
super earthquake that was gonna make it
slide into the ocean and again that
killing people was gonna help that
somehow yeah I don't know I'm not I'm
not crazy so I don't really know what uh
yeah so I don't think he killed I don't
think he shot all his victims I think
someone were stabbed some over there
like beaten with a baseball bat [ __ ]
like that he was actually diagnosed as a
paranoid schizophrenic
he was eventually convicted of 10 counts
of murder so his [ __ ] was going on
around the same time as Kemper [ __ ] and
as I said they tried to pin some a
campers murders on him because
catch camper until later on now oh let's
see
so how we doing on time let me see
are we all ready oh goodness we're all
ready in an hour maybe we shouldn't
break before we start talking about the
murders yeah yeah all right so we are
going to take a break right now when we
come back we will talk about Edie
Kemper's murder spree and how he got
caught we will be right back
and just what's he doing did you do him
in the cookie you're just gonna hang out
money to monitor pretty cool huh
[Laughter]
hanging out by Mama's monitor you are so
funny
oh my goodness this is a new mint cat
toy that I got for them they're really
into it in my write Beijing did super
minty and fun yeah I know she's like why
are you filming me stop filming me you
love true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
babies case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume three is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
all right we're back now before the
break I was talking about Santa Cruz in
the early 1970s and how there was more
than one serial killer running around
and everybody was like [ __ ] freaking
out and buying guns and thinking they
were gonna get murdered and all this
other kind of stuff and how it was for a
short time the murder capital the world
although as I've said on a show before
the London Ontario I would like a word
with you
they had way more serial killers running
around at this time some but those
Canucks up there and of Iceland that's
just some weird reason it was like super
bizarre we did an episode about that
like a long time ago check it out
alright so at this point like after Edie
Kemper gets out of the mental hospital
and like I said the doctor said please
don't send him back to live with his mom
but he ended up living back Lu's mom
anyway now she was living in Santa Cruz
at the time she was actually working at
the University of California at Santa
Cruz the campus there she was an
administrative assistant now as I said
before like all of her friends and
co-workers on the campus thought she was
pretty awesome so I don't know like I
said I don't I don't know how much of
this like ballbusting personality is her
or is her son's perception of her so
invention of or invention of I'm Gino
I'm not making a stand on her they
didn't time it from that point of view
but now that you brought that up yeah
just because he talks about every female
party in his life the same way just
because he says that doesn't mean that's
what happened that motherfucker's prior
lying piece of [ __ ]
because he did like change yeah some of
his stories slightly like as he talked
because like I said he talks a lot so
he's one of those that blames others
yeah he really doesn't seem to take any
responsibility yeah even though it kind
of something made me that way that way
right and then yeah basically he'll say
something almost exactly like that
word-for-word and it's like even though
sometimes it sounds like he'll say
something that seems like he has some
empathy for the victims or something
like that but then when you listen to it
back you're like not really it's always
kind of like he's always kind of like
making himself seem the victim but in a
way that makes it not seem really
obvious that he's doing that like I said
he's very good at that now one thing
that because his mom worked
that the campus there in Santa Cruz I
kind of feel like an Kemper has said
this too and like interviews that he I
think he kind of expected his mom to
like introduce him to girls that went
there yeah this ain't India that's what
I mean it's like that is that really her
responsibility I mean you know is that
her job like to procure women for you
that's very weird but apparently he did
but according to him his mom said
basically that those girls were too good
for you you know you don't need to be
messing with them they're going places
you know they don't amount to something
someday bla bla bla I don't know if
that's true but that's what ed Kemper
said then that's true but that's what I
mean and it's that's not what she told
it maybe she just like well those girls
are going yeah those girls have
prospects yeah how you gonna compete
with that you know like I said it's you
know it's kind of like yeah it's kind of
harsh but in a way it was kind of trite
as well that's why a lot of these losers
like campers some of them ABI and Pete
oh so you don't mean and they go down to
[ __ ] they're trying to pick up girls
at kindergarten yeah they can impress
that girl well same thing with this
would this guy with necrophilia and
stuff like that it's like you can
impress a dead girl and yeah there's no
expectation yeah for you to do anything
like to impress her obviously now one
thing that he does say now I will say
that when he's interviewed about his
teenage years and about how awkward they
were and about how sexually
inexperienced he was he does seem very
forthcoming in telling like some kind of
embarrassing anecdotes about himself no
he did like go out on dates and [ __ ] now
he did say that he went out on this one
date with this girl and he had to like
of course say that she was like super
good-looking and everything it's like I
don't know what she really looked like
but maybe he was just saying that yeah
but um so he was saying that he took her
on a date to a John Wayne movie and then
to Denny's and then like he said dinner
and they said that like oh that didn't
work out and she never spoke to him
again and stuff like that even though I
didn't like probably in the 70s that
wouldn't be quite as tacky
this when he was in high school um no
because he was in the institution he
didn't get out until he was like 21 or
22
so it was like trying to date remember
back in high school used to go to the
movies and then hang out at Danny's yeah
yeah take your girlfriend out to the
Chinese restaurant yeah and then go part
but you're like 16 17 yeah it's like you
know a lot of money like somebody's just
and they're not expect John they're not
expecting right you're happy on the
house yeah yeah it's just not too much
that like it like I said I'm not a snot
it's like I don't really I didn't like
Denny's pancakes I'm all Western omelet
moons over my hammy moons everybody's
Western on a southern I'll have it down
remember the omelet they had the day my
my food yeah white country gravy with
the sausage in oh yes yeah you know what
though it's like when I used to UM what
up one place I used to work I think it
was when I used to work for Van Gogh
vodka was it or maybe it was like some
other place that I used to work but
there was a Denny's like right very very
close to it so sometimes if I cuz I
usually brought my lunch but if I was to
lazy to make it or and brought I was
like oh you can call Denny's and you can
go get you know you can go pick it up
and I would always get one of them
skillet scrambles man yeah I'm just
kidding they would pack they would pack
it all up about superbirds
only their breakfast kind of only their
breakfast food is worth the [ __ ] it's
like I feel like if you're gonna go to
Denny's get breakfast food you don't I
mean I'm sure I liked it all I'm sure
some of their other stuff is fine I
liked it all I was dropped most of time
that I was there well that helps yeah
that's kinda when we were drunk we used
to like it always get a waffle house
yeah it's like Waffle House but better
it's a little and it was always you
never knew like what was gonna happen
you'd be in there like 4:00 in the
morning yeah everyone a fine Saturday
and everybody wanted to fight you
dressed up hey matrix as being norm all
the time talking
[ __ ] hot sauce jelly yeah put it on
put it on my sausage sandwich sausage
biscuit cuz it's right cuz it's pretty
yeah said why do you put that on there
cuz this is braised free it's free he
knows damn everybody understands free
[ __ ] yeah but yeah so as I said you know
Ed's seemed to have this weird thing
like he he was mad because his mom
wouldn't introduce him to all these
quote-unquote coeds like I said I hate
that [ __ ] term but um you know and
and he had tried to take some of them
out on dates and it didn't work out
apparently because they didn't like John
Wayne movies nor did they like Denny's
unless she had said she would see boy
westerns cuz some girls are but it's
like that seems like a weird that's
movie guy movie because apparently ed
Kemper was like a big John Wayne fan
yeah but yeah that is not a date movie
yeah you don't have to go see something
like it's like I'm not a person that
likes chick flicks or anything like that
understand how hard that if somebody
wanted to take me out a day to see a
horror movie I'd be all about that I
could understand how hard that might be
for Edie being on his own trying to
figure out how to date well it he had
missed a substantial chunk of older
teenage years right we learned to date
from other guys ya know I mean where are
you gonna take her you know they kind of
[ __ ] ya know take her there man you
[ __ ] crazy are you so stupid yeah
don't don't go down there man you come
with us we're gonna go down group dating
high five and across the damn Bank Group
D yeah like you did yeah it sounds
sounds nasty when you see it now it was
a sign of a porno movie but at the time
really because like time is just it's
just like everybody was with that
everybody was like everybody knew each
other well any stage it wasn't just cars
I mean it happen to like when you was
like someone's parents were away and
like everybody went to the party over
there there were teenagers and it was
just having sex in different parts of
the living room or whatever it's like
you didn't get out of the house all that
often so we saw that movie
about them little kids let's call good
boy bad boy good boy good boys they gave
me hope that maybe there's a hope for
the future they will grow up as feral as
we did well the kids in that were very
like like that in their review we're
very similar to like [ __ ] the high
schools everything will be okay
hopefully high school is still a good
experience yeah I liked high school I
didn't like junior high that sucked but
so yeah so as I said Ed's kind of like
like I said you can kind of feel sorry
for him because he's kind of like thrown
into the dating world the people are
different than he remembered because
like I said the whole hippie thing had
happened and like everybody was all you
know peace and love man and everybody
was doing LSD and whatnot and he didn't
know anything about that so you could
see that he was kind of like swimming
and he didn't really have anybody to go
to for like advice or anything of that
nature now as I said he was kind of like
a cop groupie and actually one of his
friends from back in the day who was a
cop called him that in those very words
and a documentary that I saw so since he
couldn't be a cop because he was too
tall he started hanging out in this
place called the jury room which is like
a cop bar now the interesting thing
about this is that it was pretty much
all cops there and they thought he was
cool they thought he was great they
called him Big Ed you know he would go
in there and he would talk to them and
they would talk to him they would talk
about the cases they were working on
they even talked about like once he
started killing people like later on
like he'd already killed his
grandparents but you know what it's
interesting too about him killing his
grandparents not only did they let him
go after he was in there saying he was
safe and normal
they also sealed his juvenile records so
the cops would have never know the cops
wouldn't have known because they thought
that that would help him like get jobs
and [ __ ] later on if you know if his
records were funny is had he become a
cop
maybe this none of this would have
happened maybe I don't know there's a
chance there is there may be maybe
there's like a lot of maybes it's like
but I guess there's no way of knowing is
because if he'd been in with cops maybe
he could have had
in his mind respectable friends and
there would have been like an esprit de
corps and more of a positive influence
on me maybe he would have left that
behind and become a normal high
functioning psycho the psychopath like
oh there's lots of them they are
positive and a lot of them do well
yeah well I'm do very well like I said
if you don't have the whole scuzzy
serial killer angle yeah there's a lot
of those personality traits prosper art
yeah because there's something that's
being super confident being like you
know what I mean it's it's something
that makes you more likely to be
successful in that environment had he
done some cool [ __ ] he would have gotten
kind of like the approval from people he
respected so that kind of [ __ ]
expectation of being the good guy may
have actually pushed him in another
direction Consular maybe yeah what's 4d
Angela it's possible didn't work for da
look because he was a cop yeah he was a
cop but you can't pay them they're all
there they're all they're individuals
yeah they're not all the same I mean a
lot of them have similar personalities
but like you said they all have their
own little who knows how many bad
[ __ ] joined the cops in kana
and didn't go like that didn't go that
way see that's what I mean you never
know because yeah what if there would be
even more of them if you had certain
things hadn't happened in a particular
way that's like an interesting kind of
thought experiment but yeah so he was
hanging out with cotton like once he
started his killing spree
these cops would like discuss because
they didn't know who it was like killing
all these hitchhikers so he would
discuss the case with them and that was
another thing that helped him you know
kind of because he understood like
investigative techniques he understood
psychology he understood all of this
kind of [ __ ] so this is the thing if he
hadn't turned himself in he probably
would have got away with this for a very
very very long time man a serious egg on
the face of the cops huh yeah because
none of them had a single anklet they
hung out with him all the time so he had
inside information on his case yeah leap
sound at night knowing that they weren't
honest that they weren't on his shell
and that they were so in fact when he
called them to turn himself in later on
they didn't believe him they're shocked
they didn't believe him
he had to call them like several
and no seriously and maybe the world
would have been very different had they
not had that [ __ ] height required
maximized yeah I didn't know what I
didn't know they had a maximum height
requirement that's very weird yeah I
mean I guess I can see why maybe so
bulletproof vests that big that's what I
mean a lot of there would be a lot of
problems engendered by somebody that's
cuz that's but you would think they
would say like you're so big you have to
buy your own [ __ ] if you want the you
know yeah because seriously i this guy
said ed Kemper is six foot nine I
briefly dated a guy who was six foot
five and even that guy was enormous like
as I'm only 5'4 [ __ ] three you know
what I mean so it's like he's like twice
my [ __ ] size so I can imagine like
Edward Kemper was like Edmund Kemper was
like [ __ ] he's just like this
gigantic freakish yeah these long
[ __ ] arms [ __ ] it's like although
theories you would think that would be
great in law enforcement you would think
that big imposing you could be like the
enforcer yeah yeah you would think
because you'd be terrifying yeah weird
yeah but yeah so he starts hanging out
at this bar with all the other cops now
he also took like a bunch of different
jobs you know labor type jobs but then
he finally ended up getting one that he
had for a while which was on the
Division of Highways California Division
of Highways so he worked there and he
actually started earning enough money to
enable him to move out of his mother's
house and move into his own apartment he
was he was either lived alone or lived
with a roommate but I guess the roommate
wasn't really there a lot of the time
because of the [ __ ] that he would get up
to with some of the victims I can't see
how the roommate would be there
he also about this time he bought a
motorcycle now he was almost immediately
in two separate bricks now one of the
wrecks he actually I guess it was the
other person's fault so he ended up
getting an out-of-court settlement of
like fifteen thousand dollars and with
that fifteen thousand dollars he bought
a yellow Ford Galaxie which looks kind
of like a cop car you know right so he
again cop groobie
why don't the bars
very weird Authority yeah so in this
Ford Galaxie he starts um outfitting it
with like all this kind of you know cop
[ __ ] like and he starts picking up
hitchhikers now he doesn't kill any
hitchhikers for quite a long time so
some people have been calling this like
his practice period now according to him
he picked up about a hundred and fifty
hitchhikers now he says both male and
female most sources I've seen said you
know they were just female what he was
doing was he was trying to find out the
best way to get somebody to get in his
car like the best way to be like
disarming right you know how he can lure
them in there
the best way to keep them from getting
out but mostly he was trying to learn
how to keep people at ease and I think
he was also kind of getting off on
because here's what he would do like at
first he just had like a radio and a
microphone and [ __ ] like that in his car
but then and then he would pick people
up and then he would just take them to
their destination like a normal person
but then as time went on he would start
adding things to his collect he would
put a gun in his car but he would hide
it but he wouldn't kill the person so it
was he was like escalating he liked the
thought that oh there's a gun in the car
and I could kill this person but I'm not
I'm to see if you know I fighting keep
myself from doing he's learning the
ropes learn how to pick him up
what the transactions like yeah what
it's like when they went delivers him to
a place he's learning about can't he
keep a weapon concealed what would it be
like if he pulls it out so yeah going
through the damn training like you said
yeah yeah for he did this for quite a
long time right he's feeling about and
one thing that he said and I this kind
of struck me when I was watching because
like I said I watched several hours of
interviews with him was that one thing
he said was that you can't he's like
when you pick up cuz he's like a lot of
FEMA even though you know it was more
freewheeling back then and like people
would hitchhike and they would get in
cars with pretty much anybody he's like
but a lot of the women obviously were
wary um you know especially just a
single guy
in a car so he's like so I found one
trick that he liked to do he's like
don't ever look like you're too
desperate to pick them up he's like what
he liked to do was he's like I would do
this thing like I was a businessman and
I was on my way somewhere he's like I'd
always when they were looking in the car
he's like I'd always look at my watch as
if to say oh I don't know if I have time
to take you you know what I was like he
didn't really want to do it but then he
was trying to be a nice guy he's like so
it looked like I was kind of like like
thinking about oh maybe I shouldn't he's
like and that would put them at ease
because I wasn't like sitting there
going hey get in the car you know what I
mean like so he understood to kind of
look like detached and like not you know
to me so he would seem more
non-threatening so that was something
that struck me of him saying that he
would always like look at his watch like
oh I don't know if I have time to take
this person you know wherever it is they
want to go so he did this for quite a
long time and like I said as time went
on he estimated it was about 150
hitchhikers like I said he said man at
men and women I don't know if that was
true or not so but he you know kept
adding things to the car one thing he
would do - I think after a certain time
he would like put like a chapstick kind
of thing like behind the handle so like
it couldn't be opened or he took the
handles out or something like that like
so you wouldn't be able to get out so
now now comes May 7th 1972 now this was
his first murder other than his
grandparents so these were two girls
named Marianne Peche and Anita Lucia now
they were both students at Fresno State
College they were hitchhiking to
Stanford so they get in his car and at
this point like they didn't show up
where they were supposed to go and their
parents obviously reported them missing
like right away but as I said a lot of
people hitchhiked back then there was a
lot of you know transient kind of
population so the police didn't really
take it all that seriously thinking oh
maybe they just you know went off with a
boyfriend maybe they were just
hitchhiking bla bla bla they weren't
really super worried about it which
seems kind of weird but whatever what's
funny about him
but on these cases were getting ready to
talk about right now when I was a little
kid not a little kid but teenagers are
growing up
excuse me perfect these cases we talked
about on Geraldo yeah never Geraldo show
and Sally Jessy Raphael they would go
over Emma Kemper and like victims that
survived and weird [ __ ] like that they'd
have people talk about the cases when
you talk about these cases it's bringing
back
Geraldo to me yeah Geraldo daytime talk
show yeah that's the first time I've
ever heard of these and it's kind of
giving me that installs a feeling and
everything for that time that era I
always wondered I was wondering this I
was watching one of the documentaries
and I was watching Edmond talking about
one person that he had picked up and he
had thought about killing them but he
didn't end up killing them and then I
always wondered if that girl when she
was older like after he got caught like
did she see that and realize yeah that
was her and like I wonder too like all
of these people that he supposedly
picked up hitchhiking cos it was
apparently a lot of people it's like can
you imagine
I'm just practicing on him like not like
I would ever hitchhike but a lot of
people did back then and it's like you
know what I mean later on like he gets
[ __ ] caught and was like [ __ ]
people's heads and stuff you're like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I was in the car
with that dude with pride tease them
long enough let's get these cases he's
in jail let's eat let's see what
happened what this dude do so ok so he
picks out Marion pêche and Anita Lucia
yeah now what he did he drives him
around he said obviously that he was
gonna take him to their destination but
then he ends up like going off on this
like kind of remote road he took his gun
out and threatened them with it he took
he put Anita in the trunk like he locked
her in the trunk then he kind of like he
starts working on Mary Ann now he
handcuffs her laser across the backseat
face down now he was going to actually
smother her he puts a plastic bag over
her head and then tried to strangle her
like with a piece of a towel or
something like that
she bit through the bag
so she could breathe again so he's had
kind of having a hard time and he even
said like in some of his interviews he's
like you know it's harder to smother
somebody it's harder to stab somebody to
death in the movies like would lead you
to believe so I guess he didn't really
prepare for that kind of I guess he
thought it would be easy
so he's like trying to get people died
easy they don't yeah he even said like
you know in the movies you stab someone
once and they just fight oh and fall
over I was like that's not how it works
and that wasn't outworked innocent
you've been following the program for a
long time you can see over and over
again first and stab 45 times 72 times
you'd be like why would you stand for
that cuz that's how many it took
standing people is not you know like I
said you always see in the movies it's
like they throw a knife at someone's
back and they just fall over dead it's
like that never happened not a lot you
could live easily with that and not a
lot of stopping power in a knife no we
know girls that stick metal spikes
through their back and suspend
themselves from ceilings for fun yeah I
mean they come down like nothing even
happened it'd go right through the bar
and start drinking yeah yeah you can
stab somebody a lot and if you don't hit
a vital artery and they don't bleed out
a lot you know I mean there are certain
places where you can stab somebody any
martial artist would know with knife
combat but these guys here or not
they're not thinking they're not in
combat they're trying to murder somebody
yeah yeah they're usually stabbing him
in the chest
yeah that's not where all those arteries
are stuff like any armpit behind the
back of the knee you know in the groin
Nick yeah that's where the big I mean it
was like the thing that he said and this
was another thing that he said that
struck me when he was talking about
killing his first victim and he was
talking about you know in the movies you
know you stab somebody once and they
fall down dead he's like no but he's
like stabbing in real life it's like he
said they leak to death yeah bud loss
there's a video there was a video on
youtube of a guy in Turkey running in on
his wife while she's working as a damn
cashier and they're having a divorce is
in Istanbul he starts knife in her to
death and you can watch it it might be
taken down now but
the cops put it up there and she's
screaming bloody murder he must have
stabbed her 30 times and when he left
she was still alive
yeah and I'm written about like yeah
people that were stabbed like multiple
times you have lived and it doesn't look
like stabbing it looks like punching
yeah and I mean when you're watching it
too the black and white security cam
yeah you're like yeah not much really
going on there but he's driving a 5-inch
blade they were well I've heard that in
one particular case that I was thinking
where it was a little girl I believe it
was Wendy Mullen and she was just
walking down a street and a dude walked
by and stabbed her in the stomach and
she died later but I mean she was just a
little girl she was only eight or nine
or something and um they never caught
the guy that did it by the way um but
she went to the fire station and told
them that the guy had punched her in the
stomach she wasn't she didn't realize
she missed
she'd been stabbed she said it just felt
like he hit her with the fist but she
hadn't she'd been stabbed to the hunting
knife and like I said she died later she
watched through a CCT camera that's what
it looks like looks like some guy doing
this yeah and the reaction of the girl
is just wow
it doesn't look that serious yeah you
know she screams and then he runs off
like I said you really have like work to
get a yeah to get to like a vital organ
right and even then it kind of takes a
while you know a knife is not a sword
now and it's also not a pistol or a
rifle yeah yeah and like I said at this
point I mean at kemper had only killed
his grandparents and he shot both of
them with it Ronnie - so stabbing and
smothering her entirely differently so
so like I said he's trying to you know
he's trying to smother her she bites a
hole through the bag he's trying to
strangle her the like the cloth that
he's using to do it like snaps so then
he starts stabbing her like he starts
stabbing her in the back and stuff like
that and she's just struggling and
screaming and everything and then
finally she finally he ends up just
slashing her through so she did she did
die then yeah it's funny these guys
they're kind of attracted they want to
be rapists they want to be murderers and
they're somehow it
tracted two knives like you said and
then they go throw this problem it's
gotta be kind of a sexual thing they're
looking at that boy it is like a
penetration they're thinking oh yeah
that's what I want to use really for you
know for a non firearm weapon if you
want something that is effective and
quick it's always blunt force trauma
yeah and not a hammer about yeah you
know hammers you know we've we've seen
the evidence through all the friends at
cabinets before hammers just pop a hole
in a skull and then you can't get the
damn hammer out yeah and then it doesn't
kill that person you would think that it
would but not right away except at
kemper killed his mom with a hammer
yeah well that did kill her it doesn't
kill me
yeah you know it's not like a one blow
and they're dead no they were gonna
figure it so that's a pretty horrible
death because like you said it takes
like several takes example because I've
I've written about a bunch of cases
where people kill people with hammers
and it was yeah it took several but one
massive blow where the baseball bat
usually kills a person yeah if it's a
head not even an axe is not even an axis
as good no because like I said he built
like the [ __ ] axe man of New Orleans
like a lot of his victims lived even
though he hit him in the head where that
axe with an axe yeah there's a damn
transgender person on video now it was
over in Australia and you can see you
know she he walks it what's a she I
guess walks into a damn 7-eleven and hit
that guy right in the [ __ ] center of
his face with an axe he lived and then
he hit that hit the girl with the axe
and I think she died and that person got
sentenced there like 15 years I think I
I think I think the girl died maybe
maybe she live - but ya know axes are
nowhere near as effective as people
think I mean it's gruesome like yeah
sure you know and it does work sometimes
so you know Villisca ax murders and [ __ ]
like that you know and [ __ ] what
Silas I looked at the statistical data
if you when are you talking about melee
type weapon the one with the biggest
body count and the most effective
[ __ ] baseball bat yeah it does seem
less a reliable killer yeah
for headshots maybe not you know torso
but well yeah that's you strike somebody
and hit with a baseball bat full force
it yeah it almost always kills them yeah
and there's no response the person just
goes down but you know they're not
choosing this [ __ ] to be efficient no
yeah that's what I mean I don't I don't
think that has any I don't think I need
to do it
they for some reason they're attracted
that blade on that night like I said
it's like it's like a peanut sex thing
it's right it's like a penis yeah a
placement is what it is it's a penetrate
out of you gotta meet that blade no yes
I need to have yeah it's like a sharp
dick right yeah you know yeah yeah so um
he was finally able to kill Marian pêche
then he took the other girl Anita
lutessa
out of the trunk and stabbed her as well
now the [ __ ] up thing about this is
that he puts the bodies into the bodies
are in the car and he drives around in
the car with the bodies in there for
like quite a while now he said later on
and this might be true because this is
something you could probably check he
says that while he was driving around
with the bodies in the car or in the
trunk he got pulled over by a cop for a
broken taillight and he said that he was
like super super excited the whole time
that like he was drive around with these
bodies in the car and the cop was like
right there it's like if he opened the
trunk he'll see like two dead girls in
the trunk but the guy didn't cuz it was
just a broken taillight I didn't see a
note I mean great reason to check so he
didn't have a check check so okay so he
takes the two girls bodies back to his
apartment he takes all their clothes off
and starts dissecting them what he would
do is he would usually be had them he
would take pictures like before he was
like taking each piece off so almost
kind of like Jeffrey Dahmer it was very
similar and he had a similar
justification he would say that he
wanted to make them mine okay now he's
doing this where in the bathtub
um I guess I'm not really sure okay you
ain't do that over carpet well yeah
because you'd never get that gel
I mean
maybe he had hardwood floors maybe even
tile
you can't scrub that [ __ ] out well you
know I've dressed deer and butchered him
down into nothing and you know there's
once the internal organs out after after
a deer's field rest it's actually a much
cleaner and less bloodier you know
process than people think it looks like
something out of your damn grocery store
it doesn't look like something out of
one of these horror movies that's really
what it looks like and a person would be
the same thing is that you're dealing
with a person but I don't think these
guys have the backgrounds are the skills
doesn't know how to butcher so I would
think they've been [ __ ] it up pretty bad
well that's what I mean I would think
yeah they're probably doing this well
internal or with internal organs inside
the body yeah yeah you know I mean that
can get kind of messy yeah cuz you just
don't do that with deer you know any
kind of game you know you want to get
those internal organs out you don't want
to take any of the meat and that's where
all the weight is anyway they get a lot
of lighter once all that comes out yeah
but yeah where's he doing this see they
never really said I think I think in one
case they did say it was in the tub yeah
but see the thing is that he got like I
said I don't think he raped any of the
victims while they were still alive or
conscious anyway so I think his whole
thing I mean he was a necrophiliac like
you said I think it's because he was
afraid of women he was afraid of
disappointing them or that they were
gonna laugh at him or whatever so he had
to wait till they were dead to have sex
with them and what he would do is he
would usually cut their heads off then
he would have sex with the head like
oral sex with the head and then he would
[ __ ] the headless body also so that's
nice yeah so the internal organs are
still in there I would imagine yeah it
does I don't think he like took him out
or anything that's nasty
well yeah so and then another thing that
he would do too and what he did with
this first one was he would somebody
would take the headless bodies sometimes
he would cut them up further and would
wrap him in plastic or something and he
would go and dump them in different
place like he would dump them look like
in a ravine or like in
the ocean or something like that now
sometimes he would keep the heads for a
while I'm assuming for sexual purposes
and then later he would get rid of them
so that you know there was one like one
horrible image where he said something
about being sitting in his living room
and just having these two like girls
heads like on the arm of the couch like
he was like talking to him and [ __ ]
messed up yeah so now he had done this
he had done the ultimate thing and he he
said in like interviews later that you
know the first time you do this it's
like you know it's like shocking you
can't discuss ting and can't believe he
did it and stuff like that and I'm like
I answer that by that but anybody know
anyway no minds it he wasn't
yeah like nobody suspected him now at
this stage the cops only knew that these
two girls were missing because they
didn't find their bodies until that's
actually I believe Anita Lu chesa I
don't think they ever found her head or
her body was he eating them now okay in
a couple of statements he did say that
he was eating that okay I think but then
later and and a lot of like
psychiatrists that studied him said even
if he didn't say it he is like seems
like that type of like a cannibalistic
type of sanity like his he wanted to
like a possession like he wanted to keep
them with him like Dahmer did I'm
thinking just just have just just having
a background in deer hunting if you're
gonna go through the problem taking that
thing home and cutting it up and having
sex with it haven't said well I don't
have saved a deer but I'm just saying
you would think that he would probably
eat some too yes and I mean it's free
yeah it's free yeah yeah I mean so why
wouldn't he eat some and like I said he
did say at one point that he had eaten
parts of the bodies yeah and some of the
psychiatrists that studied him said yes
he probably don't have because that is
you know that's usually something that
people have that personality it's not a
bunch yeah
but later on he recanted that because he
said oh I just said that at my trial
because I was trying to get an insanity
plea because at the trial he had already
confessed everything so that's the only
defense they could see
yeah I I am too I kind of feel like
maybe he what happened is he kind of
cooled off and he says maybe I should
have told him that maybe that's gonna do
far yeah I think maybe yeah like having
sex with the [ __ ] sevens pad isn't
bad enough it's going too far
yeah that's what he's thinking in a way
I almost feel like having sex with a
secretary severed head is like worse
yeah I would say having sex with his
Milaap worse than eat it you know I mean
they have people I mean they're booked
bad obviously but it's like other
countries that eat do ritualistic
cannibalism they eat their own relatives
did during the damn funeral yeah I mean
you know it's not common anymore but
[ __ ] they were doing that in India up
until it kind of recently I think yeah
wasn't there guy from vice when the
reporters from vice news actually was in
on some kind of weird cult in India that
still practices it kind of throwback
weird I and then they go well okay you
know free meet Freddie for everybody
they eat it they're dead anyway
which I could see that it's I know it's
[ __ ] up when you I can see where they
have some Connor when you kind of think
of of ritualistic cannibalism in nature
with you know pre-industrial societies
really what you're talking about is
extreme poverty yeah in a place where
meat is very hard to come by and when a
loved one dies they're giving you the
gift of something well that's how they
see that's how they would see in this
how their culture saw it but in a day
where you can go down get some damn
chicken breasts for a [ __ ] you know
no man dollar 69 a pound that yeah it's
like why would you that's it it's not me
up honestly all around the world I mean
there's a taboo against Kent about
cannibalism for a reason that it's very
like ingrained you know and most species
have that yeah I kind of think though in
kind of in the hominid period you know
we're talking about tens of thousands of
years ago different types of humans
probably waged war against one another
and ate each other yeah because there's
a lot of evidence about those ancient
campfires
fill the bones and they were hominid
bones yeah they were eating each other
and I always wonder if it was just
because hey free meat or it's like hey
[ __ ] you guys I think it's both
yeah it's it's you know I mean it's free
meat and you guys came in here a h8 I
hate you so much I'm gonna eat you
nourish myself and then [ __ ] you out
yeah you know I kind of feel like
there's excess yeah it's win-win yeah
and it's kind of like headhunters also
rather you know they're doing that same
kind of mentality I hate you so much my
shrink your head down and I'm gonna use
your head it's proof that I [ __ ] took
you out yeah yeah I mean so weird around
my neck yeah show it to other people to
intimidate them you know it makes sense
it makes sense in primitives warrior
societies yeah because their take on it
is gonna be very different from a modern
person this is happening up until
recently no but like I said you can
understand you can still understand
where they're coming from though you
don't like that it's not like some weird
alien concept no it's basically gang
warfare in a general like I mean it's
[ __ ] up and like you know we don't
have any experience with that but you
can still understand why they would
think that you know what I mean so
alright so at this stage like I said the
the two girls that he had murdered were
just considered missing because they
didn't find their bodies until later on
so no one suspects begin of anything now
his next victim he picked up on
September 14th 1972 now this was a
little girl named Aiko Koo she was 15
years old now she was going to a dance
class and she had either missed her bus
or the bus didn't come or something like
that and she got sick of waiting at the
bus stop so she decided to hitchhike and
unfortunately it was Edie Kemper who
picked her up now the odd thing about
this case was that I mean she was like I
said she was only 15 she's very and she
was a tiny tiny little girl he seemed to
like pick you know as as large as he is
he always seemed to pick very very
slender and very very petite girls they
didn't all look this
it wasn't like a Ted Bundy of the dark
hair parted in the middle type of thing
even though all Ted Bundy's victims
don't look like that but he kind of
picked girls that looked kind of all
different but they were all small
they're all pretty small the opposite of
him yeah that's kind of what you know
and and like I said I think it was kind
of going back to what you said about
pedophiles too where it's like you feel
intimidate he would feel intimidated by
a woman that was closer to his size so
he always picked somebody it's almost
like picking on kids and really well
this girl is a kid she's only 15 years
old so he picks her up now he has the
gun in a car in the car and he starts to
he drives her to like a remote area and
he starts to like threaten her with it
now he says at this point she's like
freaking out he says I don't know if he
said that he was gonna kill her or he
was gonna kill himself now what he ended
up doing was that he locked himself out
of the car with the gun still in there I
don't know if he did that on purpose
like to test her or if he did it
accidentally I've heard because like I
said different interviews at different
times because they've interviewed him
many times like over the years because
in prison for so long his story kind of
changes from thing to thing so in one
account of this he says oh I
accidentally locked myself out of the
car and the gun was still in there and
then another one he implied that he kind
of did it on purpose to see what she
would do you know what I mean hmm so
he's locked out of the car and she's in
there with a gun and he seems to say
that because she didn't pick up the gun
and shoot him and because she let him
back into the car like she unlocked the
car door and let him back in then I he
didn't really say this outright but it
seemed like he was implying that she
deserved that she deserved it then yeah
because she was well she could have shot
me she could have not that she was our
victim so she wanted to be the see this
is what I mean about him or you can
Mayim i've ever interpreted as she did
she failed the test I kind of feel like
getting it to survive I think that's
what he was getting at yeah he didn't
say it like that exactly but I think
that's what he meant you know what I
mean it's like oh well she could have
just shot me she could have she was too
stupid to live
she was yeah I'm like she was a 15 year
old girl it's like what the [ __ ] and
it's like like I said we only have his
account to so it's like how did that
even go down we don't know that it went
down exactly like that so I don't know
there's no way of knowing so anyway so
he gets back in the car
and he he put tape over her mouth and
then he put his fingers up her nose and
he was like trying to suffocate her now
she did fight against him but she
eventually went unconscious
now after I've heard that like once she
went unconscious that he raped her like
he took her like she went unconscious he
took her out of the car later on the
ground and raped her and then took her
scarf and strangled her and then put her
in the trunk and drove away
now while her body was in the trunk he
stopped at a [ __ ] country-western bar
and sat there and had a couple of beers
with a fifteen-year-old girls body in
the trunk of his car he was in no hurry
I guess not and he said then another
thing too it's like I don't know if she
was at the bar or then like he took the
car back to his mom's house and he would
like open the trunk and like look in
there he said oh it was like a fisherman
admiring his catch is how he put it and
he's like oh if somebody would have
walked by you know they would have seen
me but nobody did right so I was like
okay nice so I cuz I kind of feel like
he has this thing like oh well since
nobody walked by that means it's okay or
he likes that kind of thrill but I think
yeah it's right here nobody sees it yeah
yeah must be okay yeah I don't know I
don't know how people like this thing
but yeah so he did the same thing that
he did to the first two girls he took
her back to he took her back to his
apartment laid on his bed he took off
her head took off her hands and he
actually dumped her body in her head and
hands in two different locations so he
was trying to cover up the fact that he
was doing this [ __ ]
so again
ie koku okay she was a Korean girl so
okay so four months go by now at this
stage there were some other murders
going on but that was that other dude
Mullin um but because that was like a
different mo so even though they tried
to pin a couple of a couple of the
hitch-hiker murders or you know
disappearances on Mullin you know they
they couldn't pin the I Coco thing on
him so in 1973 Kemper buys a 22 caliber
automatic pistol even though technically
he wasn't supposed to own a firearm
because of his prior record so but
apparently it was okay like he didn't
get any [ __ ] he just bought it the
background check system of during this
era was not as pretty it's all paperwork
just lackadaisical well no wasn't so
much that was paper mmm so it's not like
you could like you know turn on your
computer and search a name yeah and have
it [ __ ] pop up through all states
yeah they'd have to like look through
the index cards yeah states didn't
really communicate too well with each
other and yeah like as bad as it is
nowadays it's like back then is [ __ ] man
if something happened the next county
over yeah it's like it was like some big
deal it's like you stepping on my dick
and we can't do this and then this no
one was cooperative out felons getting
their hands on guns for a long time a
felon could own a gun yeah you know I
mean you came out of prison your time
was served you we had a full restoration
of Rights which actually I kind of I
kind of believe that if you're so
dangerous that you can't get your and
they say they shouldn't let you out yeah
you know I mean I think that you know
you do your time it's all good now you
paid for it you should be right back
into society you know no problems um but
you know back in those days you could be
a felon all right in your own state go
buy a gun and you had a good chance of
[ __ ] not being found out well they
didn't do it in this case yeah
the paperwork was just so you know
physical paperwork is hard to deal with
your criminal record might have been in
a damn cardboard box somewhere in some
[ __ ] storage shed from a long time
ago you know I mean how do I know one's
empty no when I were there do hear it
out you know just was not you know Dana
was difficult to deal with that day and
the thing about it was that I mean his
juvenile records had been sealed yeah
you know what I mean so I mean you know
in the pre-computer age it was pretty
much the honor system yeah how do you
fellas like can you just not like no
butter we're gonna check make sure
you're you know it's kind of hard to
actually find out yeah everything was a
pain in the ass back then like I said
that's why the some [ __ ] was cool about
the 70s and 80s but I would never go
back there everything was a gigantic
pain in the ass like no yeah you
couldn't find information no it was very
very difficult
so okay so he didn't have any trouble
buying this gun but he got kind of like
paranoid about it because he's like oh
if I get caught with it you know I could
get in big trouble and so he was worried
about the police finding him with it now
apparently this stressed him out such a
point that he's like well I gotta kill
somebody else now cuz that's how that
works I suppose so
the next girl he killed was named Cindy
shawl now he was I guess he was kind of
jazzed that he had the new gun so we
wanted to try it out on somebody as
[ __ ] up as that is so he forces her
into the trunk and shot her with his new
firearm right in the head so bullet
lodged in the skull now at this point
Edmond didn't live in his own apartment
anymore he had been I guess I don't know
if he had financial problems or
something like that but he had actually
had to move back in with his mother she
had a she lived in a duplex so he brings
the bond I'm assuming the mom was at
home so she was at work or out with
friends or something so he brings
Cindy's body back to the duplex and puts
it in his room now after his mom left
for work the next morning he had sex
with the dead body
and
he washed it then he dug the bullet out
of her skull so that it wouldn't be tied
back to his gun and he cut off her head
now in this one he didn't take it far
afield and like dump it like in
different places
he took Cindy shawls head and buried it
in the backyard of his mother's house
looking up at either his window or his
mother's window I've heard two accounts
of this he said that he buried Cindy
shawls head looking up toward the house
because he made the joke that oh my mom
always liked the thought of someone
looking up to her and I've also heard
him say that he buried it because he
liked thinking of her head back there
looking up at the sky and that sometimes
at night he would lay there in bed and
he would talk to that head like and like
talk to it quote/unquote like it was a
girlfriend or a wife he said [ __ ] so I
don't know which story is strained by
but that head he buried that in the
backyard of his mom's house he got rid
of the rest of the body like somewhere
else he's trying to eat he's thinking it
through too much he's trying to make up
a story he just pointed at his mom's
head he didn't like his mom that's yeah
so it's like oh there's a dead person's
head staring at that's probably closer
to and that probably gave him this
[ __ ] jolly and then he thought about
it more made-up nooks new explanations
of why he did that yeah there's probably
just a [ __ ] you [ __ ] look at the head
looking right at her like that but yeah
so like I said the head was in the
backyard the rest of the body he cut it
up and like threw it off various cliffs
and whatnot now her body was found
almost immediately like almost the next
day like the body parts most of the body
parts were found they were like washed
back onshore but because they'd been
washed because there was no link to him
they couldn't trace it him so he wasn't
super worried about it now on February
5th 1973 Edmund and his mom had another
if their huge huge fights now they did
argue a lot because neighbors reported
that they could hear them like screaming
at each other
all the time so there were so there was
a lot of fire so they did fight yeah
and a lot of times after you know after
there would be a fight just like in the
case of the grandparents where it's like
they had a fight and then he shot him
you know when they would have a fight he
would go out like looking for someone to
kill so they have a big fight on this
one particular night Edmund goes out and
picks up this girl named Rosalind Thorpe
now while she's in the car he sees
another girl who doesn't know the first
girl who's hitchhiking named Alice Louie
now he thought oh well I already have a
girl in the car so this girl will
probably not be scared because there's
already another girls car so he stops
and picks up the other one another thing
that that Edmund had to his advantage
was that he had a santa cruz College
like the campus parking sticker on the
back of his car he had gotten it from
his mom because she worked there so even
though cuz at this point like you know
obviously people were like hey don't
hitchhike around here don't because a
lot of them were students like at that
school or other schools around there and
people are like hey might not want to
hitchhike or you know if you do like
look out leave like if it's somebody
from the campus like with the sticker
it's probably fine and because they said
that he asked his mom to get him a
sticker for his car and she did so in
this case like he actually went back
onto the campus and because he had that
sticker like the guard didn't check
because they thought oh well he's just
another student or he works here or
something like that so in the back of
his car though hitchhikers couldn't see
that no with the guard okay the guard
was who I said um yeah so that was
another thing that happened so so he has
these two girls in the car now these
ones I don't think he even like took
them anywhere particularly far he what
he did in this case was Rosalind was in
the passenger seat and Alice was in the
backseat he says to Rosalynn like oh hey
look at that pretty thing over there
like out the window and then he just
[ __ ] shot her like in the head like
in the
I see him now Alice in the backseat
obviously freaks the [ __ ] out and then
he slowed down and you know just pointed
it at her and shot you know at her a
bunch of times but he was like over like
over his shoulder now she did get shot
but like she was moving around obviously
trying to get the [ __ ] out of the car so
he had to shoot her like a bunch of
times like before she actually died
now after that he took he put both the
bodies in the trunk then he stops at a
gas station to fill up the car with gas
he goes back to his mom's duplex where
he was living at the time then he opens
the trunk beheads
the girls while they're in the trunk
like while the car is parked out this is
what he said yeah he beheaded them while
they were still in the trunk and he was
just standing there on the right [ __ ]
side where the car was parked now he I
guess he left them in there overnight
because like the next morning after his
mom left for work he brings Alice's body
inside which is headless and has sex
with it in his room then he brought
roselyn's head into his room so he could
take the bullet out of her head and then
he goes to he goes to Pacifica and well
he goes like on the way he dumped like
some of the body parts then he goes to
Pacifica and he dumps both the heads and
the hands so yeah do you look horrified
yeah that's some weird [ __ ] yeah and
like I said he's like this is [ __ ] up
so he'd be handsome in the trunk
that's what he said and you think that
makes you think that make that trunk all
[ __ ] up yeah that's all that's messy
maybe you didn't know because you know
the blood pressure was down they weren't
hearts weren't beaten but still why
would you do it there yeah because I
mean they've been in the trunk for a
while
wonder what his car looked like once he
was apprehended maybe we'll get to that
huh
did they find I had you evidence in that
car I don't know not that I know I never
heard anything like that did he meet
that that's what I mean it's it's really
hard to say
now the next once he committed were
probably the ones he wanted to commit
all along so okay so his mom Claire Nell
as much as she allegedly couldn't stand
his ass and thought he was a freakin a
weirdo she never suspected that he was
the quote/unquote co-ed killer a couple
times he actually in interviews he said
Oh sometimes I wanted to just tell her
just like so cuz she would like flip the
[ __ ] out and he got off on that but he
never did tell her so it's Easter
weekend and this is about a month after
he killed the previous two victims so he
comes he's at home one night and his mom
has been out with her friends some
sources say she'd been out like drinking
or she was kind of like in debris and
when she got home some of them don't say
that so apparently she comes home and I
guess he goes in her room after she
comes home and she according to him says
something snarky to him like oh I
suppose you want to stay up and talk now
or something like that that's what she
said to him and he was like no it's fine
and he goes back to her room it goes
back to his room but then he waits for
her to fall asleep and then about 3:00
4:00 in the morning he comes in and just
beats her to [ __ ] death yeah with a
hammer yeah while she was sleeping
evidently have the blue yeah it was just
like I said it was almost like his
grandmother type of thing like it almost
seemed like he got to a point where or
you know some people have said that all
of the women that he killed were you
know just leading her to his mother like
surrogates for her because he talked
about how much he hated her like since
he was eight years old he wanted to kill
her he said according to point to where
he had to do it I guess so so not only
did he beat his mother to death with a
hammer while she was sleeping he also
beheaded her had sex with her head
damn so he
actually [ __ ] like into damn
apparently has apparently had sex with
her headless body also although sources
differ on that he put her head on the
mantel and screamed at it for an hour
threw darts at it yeah then he cut out
her tongue and her lyrics and tried to
put them down the kitchen garbage - [ __ ]
man and he said that he tried to put
them down there but it was too grisly
and so it came back up into the sink and
he thought that was very funny because
he thought it was very fitting because
of all the bitching she had done at him
done at him over the years
I wonder even the garbage disposal
rejected did they recover any of this
they did yeah well I mean that's in
pretty much every ok so yeah yeah
because scopz did go to the house cuz
you know what I mean alright so yeah he
did all that to his mom dad now for
whatever reason um see I see I don't
know what his reasoning was for this
exactly because he had already killed
his mom which like I said that was like
his Everest I suppose but either because
he didn't want the crime tied to him or
for some other reason he decided to call
his mother's best friend whose name was
Sarah Sally
Hallet he's like hey why having a
surprise kind of a little surprise
dinner for my mom why don't you come
over for dinner in the movie or whatever
and she said okay and when she got there
he strangled her to death and did the
whole [ __ ] thing with the head and
having sex with the head and the body
and everything like that so then he sort
of half-assedly tried to clean up the
duplex like he took like the mattress
where his mom was killed was all bloody
obviously he turned it over he kind of
tried to clean some [ __ ] up he took the
bodies and kind of stuffed him in a
closet and then he kind of went on the
run like he initially took Sally's car
and then he ditched that one and then he
rented another one I think it was an
Impala and he
basically drove for like three days you
know I mean I don't know three days
straight but they said he was like on
caffeine and nodoz and everything like
that and they said he was like starting
to get like [ __ ] hallucinogenic and
[ __ ] right you know what I mean so so he
drives for three days and apparently he
was listening to the radio to see if his
crimes had been discovered and was
apparently disappointed when they were
not so like I said this is very odd to
me because the whole time yeah because I
feel like one why did he kill his mom's
friend unless he wanted to make it look
like someone else had done it you know
what I mean yeah because that seems like
trying to like fob it off on somebody
else because like if it was just his mom
most people would know hey it was
probably him but he's like oh well if
this other person is dead too maybe
it'll just like look like some random
psycho you know what I mean
reading too much into it maybe but it's
like it's weird to me because then he
goes on the run for three days almost
like he's trying to escape but then he
said oh well I was worried because it I
didn't hear about it so then he calls
the cops himself yeah and says go to my
mom's house I killed them like he
basically turn himself in now like I
said he called a cop that he knew
because he hung out with all the cops in
Santa Cruz like I said at that bar so he
calls the cop that he knew and the cop
didn't they didn't believe him he
couldn't handle the anticipation I guess
not too much stress you want to know
what was gonna happen that's what it was
it was like it was like psychology is
just so weird to me I don't understand
why he [ __ ] did that was playing on
his mind I guess I'm just gonna turn out
so then he calls them and that like I
said they didn't believe him at first
and he had to like ask for like he had
to call him back like three cuz at first
they were just like yeah [ __ ] off and
they like call back later if you're
really anyone get away with it that's
what I mean it's like if he hadn't
turned himself in yes I do not know the
state I don't know if they would have
known it I really don't know the state I
don't know what happened yeah and a lot
of people have said that there'd be one
like a lot of serial killers I guess
because of like [ __ ] Hannibal and
Hannibal Lecter and [ __ ] like that like
people think of these serial killers
like oh they're smart they're
masterminds most of them are like are
idiots they're dumb but and they only
get
get caught because of like just dumb
luck or because the cops are incompetent
or for some other you know reason that
doesn't have anything to do with them
geniuses he could have said look I'm
overhearing I know the state man all I
had to do was go to like Nevada because
no one suspected yeah well the serial
killer did it yeah nobody suspected him
and like I said there were at least two
other serial killers running around it
was just the Santa Cruz area at that
time not only just like in the whole
state of California which is like serial
killer Central particularly then so it's
like he totally could have got away with
that I don't think he would have ever
got caught if he hadn't turn himself in
so in a way like he do is lie about his
time front Parcher I mean oh oh you know
as a city he could have said that he
lied and left two days before yeah I
mean as shitty as he is at least he
[ __ ] turned himself in and took
himself off the street although it would
have been nice if he'd done that earlier
but you know I mean so as I said he
calls the cops and they don't believe
him he had to call him back like three
times they thought he wasn't like just
screwing around and finally he calls
this one I think his name was sergeant a
Luffy or something like that and he knew
that guy like really closely and he's
like no seriously he's like go to my
mom's house right now and you'll find
this that and the other thing and he
told him about the [ __ ] and the garbage
disposal and everything like that so the
sergeant finally goes to the house and
sees exactly the way that he said it was
he even like left a note he had left a
note for the cops Edmund Kemper had left
a note likes saying something I'm
paraphrasing but he said something like
you know it's I wasn't being sloppy I
just didn't have a lot of time you know
sorry gents or something like that like
because he hadn't cleaned up all the
mattress and he just turned it over
because I remember like the one guy I
think they they interviewed sergeant
aloof he like on one documentary that I
saw and he's like yeah I went in there
and it's like it looked kind of clean
but then like you turned the mattress
over like in the mom's room and it was
just [ __ ] blood everywhere so yeah
now they finally believe him and they go
and do all that [ __ ] so they arrest him
now he actually as I said because he was
so forthcoming with his confessions he
basically as soon as they brought him in
he just started yappin and he went into
like super
detail he was tired of it I guess so
well he's okay
now he has said on numerous occasions
that he understood that he was a monster
and he knew that he wasn't going to be
able to stop and he knew that he needed
to be taken off the streets I don't know
if I believe him entirely but like I
don't believe necessarily that that's
what his justification was Yosa knew you
didn't have a job and he needed money
and he'd you know I mean he couldn't pay
for himself now that his mom was dead so
prison was his retirement plan and he
had actually an AC he said later on that
he had actually quite enjoyed his time
at the Atascadero like mental hospital
yeah do you think well yeah well he
really liked like interacting with the
other patients he really liked
interacting with the psychiatrist he
seemed like he had a really good time
I mean he's not worried about sex yeah
you know he wasn't getting anything
anyway seven six dead girls true which
that's what that's like
that's just masturbation pretty much
yeah might as well get a real dump
you're there by yourself yeah so yeah so
as I said because he had made such an
extensive confession it was so
forthcoming with all of the [ __ ] that he
had done because like I said they had
prior to this they had no idea and they
were all the cops that he knew were
completely [ __ ] shocked cuz they had
hung out with him all the time and they
thought he was a great guy yeah so but
because he had done that um
his defense attorney all he could do was
be like well the only defense I can have
is insanity so and that's gonna be like
kind of a hard thing because clearly he
planned a lot of this [ __ ] ahead of time
he was picking up hitchhikers he had his
car kitted out he had all the [ __ ] like
hidden and everything so it's like yeah
then that's gonna be very hard to prove
and it was indeed and even in California
you know they use what they could what
is that called the m'naghten test or
something like that where it's like the
only way you're gonna get insanity is if
you genuinely did not know that what you
were doing was wrong and they're like
clearly even though he obviously has
and problems um because of the planning
because of the way that he went about
things they're like obviously he was not
insane so all of the psychiatrist's that
analyzed him you know for the trial
found him completely sane and so he was
found guilty now he was found guilty of
the eight murders because like I said
the grandparents were when he was a
minor and he had already been
institutionalized for that so he was
found guilty they murders now at the
time there was a moratorium on the death
penalty put out by the Supreme Court so
you can only get the death penalty if I
think it was after January 1st 1974
something like that so he just came in
under the wire so he actually got a
whole bunch of life sentences like
concurrent not going anywhere now he has
actually come up for parole several
times but he either like he either
doesn't get it or he doesn't bother to
show up right he has said that he does
not want to get out what would he do
that's what I mean I I kind of feel like
and honestly from everything I've heard
they say he is a model prisoner they're
like he he is like totally polite he's
totally kind he wants everyone to forget
you you know he wants to forget his past
he [ __ ] reads audio books for blind
people it's like he counsels other you
know inmates and [ __ ] like that reads
audio books for blind yeah you know he
reads books for blind
yeah yeah you know my god like onto you
well yeah you know I meant so yeah so he
does all that kind of stuff and I should
say too you know as horrible as the [ __ ]
he did was the silver lining of it was
as I mentioned he was instrumental
you know the interviews with him that
were undertaken by the very the nascent
you know Behavioral Sciences Department
at the FBI which first came about in the
early 70s he was one of the main serial
killers that they interviewed I believe
there were 36 of them that they
interviewed they also interviewed like
many many victims or like people that
had escaped from serial killers and they
did a lot of different kills wasn't just
serial killers it was like assassins it
was spree killers it was all different
kinds because they were trying to find
you know the psychological
you know pinpoint the psychological kind
of like you know aspects of all their
personalities so he actually did end up
you know as horrible as it sounds he
actually did end up doing some good
because the interviews with him and how
forthcoming he was and how insightful he
was whether it was genuine or not did
actually aid the FBI a great deal in
coming up with profiles of other serial
killers like him and he does seem to he
seems to take a lot of pride in that
that he helped people because he was
like oh well I helped the FBI like catch
other people like me which seems like
what he wanted to do like I said it's
he's such an interesting guy to me
because I don't want to like him I don't
want to feel sorry for him I don't but
in somebody it's hard not to you know
what I mean because he does really seem
to have like a lot of insight but that
said I think that he's so manipulative
that he just puts across I don't think
anything that he says or anything that
he looks like he's feeling I don't think
any of that is genuine I don't think he
feels much I don't that's what I mean I
think he's technically I think he's a
sociopath I don't think that he feels
anything for anyone other than himself I
just think he's very good at pretending
that he does he's very emo he's an emo
killer yeah but he feels for himself not
for the victims exactly you know pretty
much like he breaks down crying like in
some of that it's like especially when
he's talking about killing his mom and
how hard it was and stuff like that I'm
like I just I have a hard time yeah I
have a hard time but I can see how other
people would be full but because he does
seem very genuine yeah but that's that's
what makes him so interesting to me and
that's what makes him so dangerous and
why I'm glad that he turned himself in
for [ __ ] sake cuz he would have killed
he could have killed like dozens
hundreds of people and not been caught
because he wouldn't have stopped I don't
think no well he did stop
yeah but I mean had he not he mean I
think he burned out that's why he turned
himself in
once he killed his mom he really wasn't
going anywhere well yeah that was kind
of like what he had wanted to do yeah
and and I think he kind of got like self
defeatist he started to like beat on
himself like oh he'll never make it
they'll be they're gonna catch me
they're gonna catch me yeah that shit's
starting to [ __ ] I'm so bad he's like
I haven't a copy
I need to call them yeah see how this
I'm just gonna worry about em yeah I
wanna see this [ __ ] turns out you know
Mary Eunice I think that's what happened
yeah it may be but like I said I do find
it very interesting and you know I've
been I had that been just a random any
innocent person that he wouldn't have
called it was because it was because it
was his mom yeah yeah yeah like I said
the relationship between him and his mom
was like super super weird yeah like
that I that the whole thing was like
totally [ __ ] up like I said I don't I
don't buy his whole oh my mom made me a
serial killer crap because I hate that
[ __ ] but it's like you know I think he
was born like that but then the synergy
that happened that happened between it
to look right feedback yeah and
sometimes it's not as something was I
think that's what the problem was mom
since that was wrong and then and then
once she started to glycol meant
something wrong with this dude then all
of a sudden he started good you know oh
she doesn't yeah because he started to
pick up on it because she was getting
she didn't trust him she and rightfully
so
right but in his mind it was like an
offense because I forgot to mention that
one thing that pissed him off about his
grandmother was that I guess his
granddad had like a 45 in the house and
he said that when he would be left in
the house by himself like his
grandparents were going out like to the
grocery store whatever she would take
the gun with her because she didn't
trust him and that made him angry yeah
that even though he probably would have
liked and like I said she wasn't wrong
right to not trust him because he wasn't
trustworthy but if you recognize that in
him he took it as an insult right so I
think like I said it was just this
horrible perfect storm
particularly between him and his mom
like you said it was her recognizing
that he was [ __ ] up and him taking
that personally like an insult because
he interpreted it as she doesn't trust
me even though she had every right not
to you know what I mean and it was just
like this really really bad situation
and as I said when he was let out of the
when he was let out of the mental
hospital when he was 21 like after
killing his grandparents I I went I just
wonder what would have happened if he
hadn't been sent back to live with her
because he didn't want to go back to
live with her and all the doctors said
you know even if his mom wasn't [ __ ]
it wasn't as [ __ ] up as he said it's
like well because he has that perception
of her then that's a trigger for him
clearly so it's not a good relationship
what for them to have what would have
happened had he become a cop yeah see
that to you there's like so many things
that could have gone differently but I
guess that's true and like any I have a
weird feeling that had he become a cop
he might have been a good cop snapped
out of it there's maybe he really wanted
to be one yeah and apparently he was
really bummed out when he found that he
was too tall yeah but yeah alright so I
guess we've gone on long enough so you
probably have doughnuts oh my goodness
yeah we have alright so we will wrap up
this show about Edmund Kemper um you
know if you want to know more about
Edmund Kemper at least of the fictional
one and how he kind of helped the FBI
and [ __ ] I want to check out the first
season of mine hunter on Netflix if you
haven't seen it second season is also
very good but like I said it's not so
much about Kemper on the second season
but the first season there's a lot of
[ __ ] about him and actor that plays him
on there is actually really good he's
actually a lot like him and there's tons
of like interviews with him on online
and stuff and if you watch him like
you'll see what I'm talking about
like why I find him so interesting and
why a lot of people think he's likable
even though I think he's a manipulative
douchebag but anyway so that will do it
for episode 159 hope you liked it
remember if you like the show like share
subscribe go to our patreon page go to
our blog good all our places give us
support give us love whatever yeah the
show help us grow share it with all your
friends anybody that you think might
like this kind of [ __ ] you know it helps
us out a lot you also check out faceless
villain 3
out in is [ __ ] salvo yeah in all the
formats if you want to read it if you
want to read it on jindo new computer
man you guys gonna love yep always
working on something I'm always working
on something my never stopped all right
so that will do it for episode hundred
fifty nine we will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]